Dies geht raus an alle, die Podcasts hören. Die Reisenden, die Camper, die Feiernden, die Hacker. Die, die sich in keinen Sendeschirm erpressen lassen. Die, die Dinge anders hören. Sie beugen sich keinen Kalender-Apps. Sie haben keinen Respekt vor dem Status Quo. Wir können sie zitieren, innen widersprechen, sie remixen oder ablehnen. Das Einzige, was wir nicht können, ist sie zu ignorieren. Weil sie Zukunft jetzt wollen. Weil sie mehr über Macs reden. Und während einige sie für verrückt halten, sehen wir in ihnen Freaks. Denn die, die verrückt genug sind, zu denken, sie könnten das Camp bereichern, sind die, die es tun. 14.8.
Ist dem so.
Jetzt doch wieder ein Planet?
Naja, so einfach ist es nicht. Also viel Aufwand, die die Amerikaner da betrieben haben, aber sie kriegen ihren Planeten nicht zurück.
Ne, also Ceres ist ja noch viel kleiner.
Hab ich jetzt Mist erzählt?
Nein, aber ich glaube, das ist eher ein Shootout mit Ceres. Aber man müsste halt auch erst mal zu Ceres fliegen, um das genau zu wissen. Ich frage mich, wenn man jetzt auf Pluto schon das Bild von Pluto sieht, was sieht man dann erst, wenn man zu Ceres fliegt?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ich finde das überhaupt so sackencool, dass sie tatsächlich nach ihres einen Planeten benannt haben.
Das einfach mal, auch wenn es nur ein Zwergplanet ist oder ein großer Asteroid.
Es ist ein wichtiges Objekt des Sonnensystems. Also es gibt nicht so viele davon. Ein Plutoid. Genau und der Mond heißt ja Dysnomia. Es wird irgendwie immer esoterischer. Ich finde das auf jeden Fall toll und Raumfahrt ist sowieso gut. Und die Amerikaner können sich immer so wunderbar freuen und sind dann immer so unheimlich ecstatisch. Ich meine, das war so richtig so eine totale Nerd-Show. Die saßen da alle so und dann We got Telemetry! Oh ja, also erst wir haben Carrier und dann irgendwie We got Telemetry und das war dann sozusagen schon das Signal, okay, das Ding ist noch in der Lage, seine Telemetrie zu senden.
Es kommt kein Random-Data, sondern ist offensichtlich nicht kaputt.
So, genau. Da waren sie schon alle ganz begeistert. Dann sind sie dann so schön die einzelnen Rückmeldungen durchgegangen von den einzelnen Gruppen. Also die Telemetrie kam an und jede Gruppe wertete die dann sozusagen aus und wurden dann eben zu der Chefin dieses, weiß nicht genau, was ihr Titel war, also diejenige, die sozusagen die Mission an der Stelle übersieht. Und die wurden dann eben zurückgemeldet, so Autonomy, alle so tolle Namen und so. Ja, no errors und alles nominal. Hast du gemerkt, wie dann so denen doch ordentlich was vor den Schultern fiel? Kann man sich irgendwie fast gar nicht vorstellen. Ich hab das ja, hatte ich ja schon mal hier erzählt, als das hier mit, na ja mit dem Kometen.
67P. Obwohl, da war es ja fast noch mehr ein Krimi, weil sie hatten einen Touchdown, aber das Ding bewegt sich immer noch und man dachte so, was geht denn jetzt ab?
Ja, der Krimi ist ja irgendwie auch noch nicht vorbei.
Jaja, klar.
Hast du das mitbekommen, dass das ja jetzt sozusagen, dass ja diese bekloppte Position von Philae ist ja jetzt sozusagen ein echtes Geschenk, weil normaler...
Weil die Sonne den nicht gleich kaputtstrahlt, weil er ein bisschen im Schatten liegt.
Exactly. Sie sind ja davon ausgegangen, dass das Ding dann zwar viel Sonne hat und noch eine Weile kann, aber dann halt irgendwann kaputtgebrannt wird und jetzt ist halt der Schattenüberhang durch diese bekloppte Position so, dass das Ding halt nicht überhitzt und jetzt können sie quasi die ganze Zeit über, sofern er halt auch weiterhin Daten liefert natürlich, können sie sozusagen den Punkt der maximalen Annäherung, ich vergesse mal, wie das heißt, perihel oder, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall, naja, perihel glaube ich, vielleicht ist es auch die andere Seite, keine Ahnung, ich bin da nicht begrifffest, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall der Sonnennächste Punkt, den der Komet erreicht, den kann halt dann viele noch überleben und dann eben auch weiterhin noch Ja, das kann ich noch machen. Wenn halt sozusagen zufällig vielleicht viele jetzt auch noch an irgendeiner Stelle gelandet ist, wo noch viel Aktivität ist, kann ja auch sein, dass du auf einmal so alles rausgasst, dann drehen die noch total durch.
Aber er sendet nicht so oft, richtig?
Ich hab sie nicht so im Einzelnen verfolgt. Das war etwas unregelmäßig und sie konnten sich noch nicht erklären, warum. Aber hat zumindest noch nicht offensichtlich aufgehört zu senden.
Aber immer nur wieder mal so ganz kurz, so für ein paar Minuten. Das heißt, die kriegen ja nicht so wirklich richtig viele Daten.
Na doch, wenn sie senden, dann ist das wohl auch verhältnismäßig konstant. Es ist nur so, dass sie sich ja immer ausrechnen, wann im Prinzip das nächste Mal wieder ein Kontakt mit Rosetta stattfinden müsste, weil die sich halt sehen und so weiter und die Programme entsprechend anschlagen. Nur das hat wohl zumindest einmal nicht geklappt und sie konnten sich nicht erklären, warum. Weiß ich nicht, steckt da jetzt grad nicht so im Newsflow drin. Hier, der Chat liefert interessante Links, nämlich, das finde ich auch immer so toll, Wolfram Alpha, Iris Pluto. Tatsächlich werden hier gleich die beiden Planeten aufgeführt. Schon weiß man, welcher weiter weg ist und größer ist.
Oh, Iris ist deutlich weiter weg. Deutlich weiter weg.
Da steht 96 AU. Ach, sehr interessant. Weil in der Wikipedia steht 68. Achso, das ist sozusagen der Apeel, also der maximale Abstand. 98 AE steht hier. Also so richtig einig scheinen sie sich nicht zu sein. Ja, das ist schon ganz schön weit weg. Ich meine, das sind 13,35 Lichtstunden. Na gut, wir sollten lieber über Macs reden.
Nee, ich will wieder reingerätschen.
Na dann grätsch.
Weil ihr seid ja gerade bei Weltraum. Ich hab, also Roddy hat ja letztes Jahr damit angefangen. Ich glaube, es war letztes Jahr, hat über den den Marzianer hier berichtet, dass das Buch ganz cool ist, dass das alle mal lesen sollten, was ich zumindest auch gemacht habe.
The Martian.
Und der kommt ja als Film aus, auch bekannt, aber jetzt gibt es auch schon einen ersten Trailer, den gibt es schon seit vier Wochen, aber da war noch nicht drüber geredet haben, wollte ich zumindest mal kurz erwähnen, damit den Leuten nichts entgeht, weil das Buch war cool. Wenn der Film genauso cool ist, dann ist der cool. Und ich glaube, alle diese Überlebensfilme, so auch Robinson-Cruise-mäßig, das spricht so den inneren Instinkt an, wie man es dann selber auch machen würde und vergleicht sich damit. Also ich glaube, die Leute finden das einfach geil.
Dann sollte ich das auch mal lesen.
Auf jeden Fall lesen. Ist halt auch so ein bisschen so für Nerds, weil er halt, der muss halt richtig basteln und sich Sachen einfallen lassen, wie er hält, da musst du lesen. Kannst ja immer noch aufhören, wenn du...
Keine Laserschwerder, tut mir leid.
Da muss ich halt immer erst mal überlegen, auf welchem Medium ich das am besten lese.
Ich habe mir einfach das Buch geschoppt.
Wie lange liest du denn so ein Buch?
Das macht so einen Spaß. Es kommt so an, wie schnell du liest. Also ich würde sagen zwischen drei Tage und eine Woche.
Ja, ungefähr.
Wenn du es richtig cool findest, bist du nach drei Tagen damit durch, wenn du Zeit hast.
Also ich glaube, ich habe es auf dem Rückflug zur Hälfte durch gehabt.
Na ja, gut, wenn man so Transatlantikflüge macht, das ist natürlich genau das richtige Zeug. Aber du hast es so auch auf Papier gelesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man so ein Buch im Flugzeug lesen will.
Ja, es gibt diese Paul's City of Books in Portland. Das ist ein Buchladen, der ist so groß wie der ganze Blog, Straßenblog. Und man ist da doch irgendwie deutlich unterwegs, in diesem Buchladen. Und die hatten halt, als das Ding neu war, hatten die halt da so, ja, unser derzeitiger Tipp der Belegschaft quasi. Und da dachte ich mir, habe ich das mit durchgelesen, ja, klang ganz spannend, habe ich das Buch mitgenommen. Und habe das dann, wie gesagt, auf dem Rückflug angefangen. Und ja, deswegen, ich habe es auf Papier gelesen. Ich habe sogar ein Buch geschoppt, da hat der Autor selber unterschrieben. Die hatten da so einen Stapel mit Signatur des Autors.
Unglaublich.
Ich bin ja so ein bisschen immer, also ich will ja eigentlich lieber digital haben. Wegen der Schlepperei.
Ist wie mit Schallplatten, die sind einfach cooler. Genau. Und davon abgesehen, wenn Radiohead ein neues Album rausbringt, das gibt es ja immer digital, aber es gibt auch das Special Fan Set. Das ist immer so ein großes Buch, irgendwie größer als DIN A4. Und da sind tatsächlich Schallplatten drin, zusätzlich noch zu der CD und zusätzlich zu den digitalen Downloads, die du da machen darfst. Also so gesehen bist du auch ein bisschen cool.
Trash.
Ja, habe ich auch noch nie ausgepackt. Das ist ja ein Sammlerstück. Ich habe auch gar kein Plattenspiel.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber...
Kannst du ja dann weiterverschenken, wenn du durchgelesen hast. Freut sich der Nächste.
Die Schallplatten?
Nein, das Buch.
Was mache ich mit den Schallplatten?
Die waren jetzt nur ein Nebenplatz. Das ist abgeackt das Thema.
Nebenkrieg schon.
Genau, wir sind jetzt beim Buch. Du kannst ja auch ein Digital-Besagen, ist mir doch Schnuppe.
Ja, ist ja in Ordnung. Ich kann mich das immer nicht entscheiden. Und dann fange ich halt an, darüber nachzudenken, ob das jetzt irgendwie, ob ich jetzt mit meinem iPad Mini und iBooks lesen möchte, was ich, sagen wir mal, von der Lesesoftware her ganz okay finde. Also wie das Buch so präsentiert wird. Und dann kommt natürlich das nächste Ding. Wenn ich mir natürlich was digital kaufe, dann will ich das natürlich ohne DRM haben. Also kaufe ich es halt nicht im iBook Store. Wahrscheinlich auch sonst nirgendswo, weil man das Buch wahrscheinlich jetzt auch gar nicht ohne kriegt, oder?
Also sagen wir mal so, der iBook Store hat immerhin den Vorteil, dass es nicht nur auf deinem iPad synchronisiert wird, sondern auch auf deinem iPhone. Und dass er die Seite, auf der du gerade liest, halt auch rüber synchronisiert, wenn die Synchronisierung von deinem iPhone wieder geht.
Ja, aber nur wenn du kaufst.
Nur wenn ich kaufe, ja.
Und das finde ich halt schon richtig arschig von Apple. Weil was ist, wenn ich jetzt mal woanders einen E-Pub kaufe?
Ja, nun.
Ja, dann ja nun. Ich habe dann versucht, in dieses scheiß iPad überhaupt erst mal das E-Pub reinzubekommen. Ja, bitteschön. Wie denn?
Du schmeißt das E-Pub auf den Mac in deinen iBox rein und dann synchronisierst du es rüber.
Achso, ja, so wie früher mit dem iPod.
Ja, genau.
Ja, arsch.
Welcher Mac irgendwie? Das ist...
Ja, genau. Du hast ja leider recht. Du kannst auch im Browser, wenn du die entsprechende Seite öffnest und da das als Download angeboten ist, dann kannst du natürlich auf den Download klicken und dann bietet ihr dir an, in iBox zu öffnen. Das geht auch. Mit PDFs kannst du das auch machen.
Da bin ich mir gerade nicht sicher, ob ich das auch ausprobiert habe. Aber was ich ausprobiert habe, ist dieses Sharing zu benutzen. Weil ich mir dachte, ich tue das einfach in meine Dropbox, mach das in Dropbox auf und dann ist es ja ein EPUB-File.
Ja, das müsste er aber auch in iBox aufmachen können.
Geht aber nicht.
Doch, du musst es nur nach iBox schicken.
Ja, ich kann nicht iBox auswählen. iBox wird mir nicht angeboten.
Nein, das mach ich jetzt kurz.
Und die einzige Möglichkeit, die ich gefunden habe, die funktioniert hat, ist, wenn du es dir selbst per Mail schickst und dann aus Mail öffnest. Dann geht es komischerweise auf einmal in iBox. Es ist so grauenhaft. Und dann liegt es natürlich nur in diesem blöden iBox auf dem iPad und du kannst den Scheiße nicht zurücksingen. Echt, Apple, das geht gar nicht. Und ich finde das auch so lame. Ich meine mal ehrlich, das ist doch lame, oder? Da haben sie ihre Scheiß-iCloud und erzählen einem die ganze Zeit, wie geil das sind. Und dann sind sie noch nicht mal in der Lage, so ein 50 Kilobyte-File zu sünden.
Aber ganz ehrlich, was mich viel mehr noch nervt, ist, wenn du dann so ein ePub gekauft hast bei einem Verlag, der da Updates zumacht. Und dann musst du versuchen, diese Updates dann in die iBook-Dings reinzukriegen. Und, äh, warte, hier, öffnen in, öffnen in, öffnen in, hier, nach iBox kopieren, geht doch.
Aus was heraus?
Aus Dropbox.
Aus Dropbox? Wieso geht das bei mir?
Also, was du machen musst, du musst das Buch...
Du hast iOS 9?
Nee, das hat damit nichts zu tun, das ging auch vorher schon. Du musst, äh, du musst das File erstmal öffnen. Dann sagst du hier Share, dann sagst du öffnen in das Ding mit dem mit dem A und dann kannst du dir die App aussuchen und da ist iBooks dabei.
Ist ja voll easy so Apple.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, das ausprobiert zu haben.
Das müsste zumindest unter iOS 8 schon gehen.
Ich probier das jetzt nochmal aus.
Okay, das ist jetzt die iOS 9 Beta 3 gewesen.
Die Spannung zerreißt natürlich die Hörer jetzt.
Man könnte natürlich die Anschaffung eines dedizierten E-Book-Readers überlegen, aber ich fürchte, das wird nicht einfacher.
Ja was soll denn das vor allem sein? Also diese Kindle-Ziege gehen ja immer überhaupt nicht. Mit diesen bekloppten Tasten. Ich weiß nicht, da gibt es jetzt auch so neue Modelle, die sind vielleicht besser, keine Ahnung.
Du, ich weiß es nicht, aber ein dedizierter E-Book-Reader hat immerhin so ein E-Book-Display.
So, jetzt habe ich hier dieses EPUB in Dropbox.
Und jetzt drückst du rechts oben den Share-Button.
Und dann, achso, und dann öffnen in App oder was?
Ja, und dann muss das E-Book sein.
Okay, also nicht, okay, okay. Jetzt weiß ich auch wieder, was mein Fehler war. Mein Fehler war, dass ich davon ausgegangen bin, dass E-Book sich selber mit einer Share-Extension, ja, okay, okay, okay, du hast ja recht.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen painful, aber es geht.
Es ist painful, aber es geht. Und maletwegen. Aber es singt halt immer noch nicht.
Nee, es singt immer noch nicht.
Idioten. Ich hab gleich noch mehr zu ranten über Apple. Keine Angst.
Apple rand, Apple rand.
Alle wollen Apple rands. Apple rands.
Wir müssen mal wieder mehr über Apple randen.
Ja, wir müssen mehr über Apple randen. Das ist wirklich, das geht irgendwie auch echt gar nicht.
Haben wir denn schon die ganzen Feedback durch?
Können wir mal machen. Ich weiß nicht, gibt's da viel zu erzählen? Nicht wirklich. Also wir hatten ja letztes Mal Ruthless besprochen. Beziehungsweise Hidden oder Restricted. Genau, wie das Flag hieß. Und das war ja das Feature, was gemeinhin vorher auch immer als Ruthless gerumored wurde. Mir wurde dann im Nachgang durch die Kommentare nochmal klar, warum eigentlich. Weil dieses Flag, von dem du gesprochen hast, was halt als Restricted angezeigt wird, wenn man ls-großo eingibt, kann man sich halt auch anders anschauen, nämlich mit xatr xatr xatr Oder mit ls-et Genau, minus et Minus Klamaffe. Und dann wird nämlich der volle Extended Attributename ausgegeben, der da lautet com.apple.rootless, warum auch immer. Ich verstehe das ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig. Also mit ohne root, also wurzellos macht irgendwie keinen Sinn, oder?
Ja, rootless im Sinne von der root kann man halt nicht mehr ändern.
Ja, ist weiß ich auch nicht. com.apple.pointless ist das.
Jetzt noch eine Backe zu featuren.
Und auf jeden Fall das Ding ist ja, um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, wenn dieses Fleck halt gesetzt ist auf irgendwelchen Files, dann kann man noch so sehr root sein, man kommt da halt nicht ran. Mit anderen Worten, das ist so richtig read-only, as it can be. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, den Scheiß zu ändern, ist halt in einen anderen State of Mind zu booten, also in so einen Installationsmodus.
In den Recovery-Modus oder wie der heißt.
Genau. Und dann darf root auch wieder ran. Und bis dahin bleibt das halt alles. Und das ist halt super für die Security, weil halt nichts mehr das ändern kann mit normalen Privilege Escalation. Solange bis irgendjemand einen Weg gefunden hat, auch dieses rootless Fleck wieder zu umgehen. Das ist natürlich noch eine andere Geschichte, aber das hilft auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr. Also es kann jetzt nicht irgendein Virus kommen. Und mal eben nur weil er root bekommen hat oder sonstige Permissions im System rumlagen. Geht erstmal so nicht ohne Weiteres zumindest. Und eine Software, die damit aber Probleme hat, da haben wir ja noch gar nicht drüber gesprochen, ist halt Backup Software. Es gibt ja hier sowas wie...
Carbon Copycloner.
Carbon Copycloner, Super Duper. Also diese ganzen Tools, die eben nicht so wie Time Machine...
Aber lesen können sie doch.
Lesen können sie, aber wenn du halt dein Backup auch wieder herstellen willst, also du nimmst halt, machst halt jetzt einen Klon.
Ja, aber du stellst doch dein Backup nicht in dein laufendes System her.
Na, wenn ich zum Beispiel auf eine neue Platte umziehen will, dann mach ich halt mit CCC eine Kopie auf die neue Platte und steck die rein und bute davon. Und die alte Platte ist halt Backup.
Ja, aber die neue Platte ist ja nicht Slash in deinem System. Doch. Nee, beim installieren aber noch nicht.
Wie beim installieren? Ich nehm mir einfach eine neue Platte, steck die ran, die ist leer, dann nehm ich CCC und mach halt eine Kopie von meinem...
Da kannst du doch.
Naja, die haben irgendwann... Ja, aber ich kann nicht die Restricted Flex setzen. Das heißt das...
Haben sie ausprobiert? Ja.
Ach du kannst Restricted Flex nicht auf einer externen...
Warum sollte man das nicht können?
Weil es nicht geht. Und darüber berichtet der Typ von...
Also zumindest können die Apps so wie sie sind, das nicht, ne?
Genau. Also derzeit können sie das halt nicht. Und das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen unklar.
Aber ein Copycloner ist auch schon so die letzte Notlösung, wenn was nicht geht, oder?
Ja, ich benutze das sehr gerne für Backups. Für Backups, ja. Also vor allem für solche Umzüge. Aber ich halte mir immer auch noch ein Notboot-System.
Ja, das ist ja eh beim Installieren immer mit da, diese 600 MB Recovery-Gingste.
Nee, ich meine nicht Recovery mit du kannst wieder was Neues installieren, sondern eine Platte, auf dem einfach das System mit den Extensions und so weiter, wie du das fährst, da ist, weil wenn jetzt hier mir eine Stunde vor der Sendung was abkackt, dann will ich halt jetzt nicht erstmal anfangen, den 24-Stunden-Prozess meines Amazon-Backups plus irgendwie Time Machine und bis der sich zusammensortiert hat und ob der denn überhaupt noch seinen Backup erkennt und ob da überhaupt noch alle Bits gerade sind. Dann nimmt man halt einfach so eine Notplatte, wo halt nicht jetzt so ein tagesaktuelles Ding ist, aber halt so von irgendeinem nennenswerten Zeitraum, wo es auch schon mal funktioniert hat. Und dann bin ich halt sofort wieder lauffähig. Kann das System booten, hab einfach ein laufendes System.
Als ich früher ein kleiner Mac-Admin war, so on the fly, hatte ich immer mein ZIP-Laufwerk mit einer ZIP-Disk und da war alles drauf, was man so braucht, um den Rechner der Leute wieder fit zu kriegen.
Einfach ein fites System und ich hab auch noch mal eine externe SSD, wo Diskwaurier drauf ist, auch sehr hilfreich. Damit kriegt man schon mal die meisten Schäden wieder gerade gebogen und eben auch ohne viel Zeit damit zu verbringen.
Eine Nebensache, die dieses Rootlist da noch mitbringt, ist, dass das neue Disk Utility unter El Capitan hat dieses Permissions Repairing nicht mehr, weil die können ja auch nicht mehr kaputt gehen, weil die sind jetzt alle restricted. Deswegen fehlt der da.
Stimmt, das ist natürlich...
Weil an dem Tool haben die mächtig viel gedreht, das ist glaube ich einmal neu geschrieben.
Sieht auch anders aus. Ist es besser?
Weiß ich noch nicht. Feature-mäßig sieht es eher geschrumpft aus, ja. Ob da noch was kommt. Also es sieht jetzt hier so wie bei iTunes und so mit Colors und so, dass sie sagen, wo was, mit was es belegt ist. So deine Daten, Fotos und Video und Audio, das zeigt er dir für deine Platte jetzt ein bisschen an.
Auch mit Assa, dass man überhaupt nie mehr weiß, was Sache ist.
Jaja, genau. Aber das habe ich auf meinem Telefon auch. Und ich kann schwören, es sind alles meine Fotos. Ich habe da irgendwie tausende von Fotos. Und irgendwie zeigt er mir dafür 2 GB an und irgendwie 10 GB Assa auf dem Telefon. Aber ich habe da sonst nichts drauf.
Was sind Daten, die geschrieben werden, um dich dazu zu bewegen, dir ein Telefon mit Speicher zu kaufen?
Nee, das ist damit, ich da mal auf iCloud irgendwie anschalte. Aber das können die ja voll vergessen.
Echt? Fährst du ohne iCloud?
Auf jeden Fall. Mir kommen meine Daten nicht in einen fremden Rechner.
Dafür habe ich Verständnis. Vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang gab es auch noch eine Frage in den Kommentaren von Flatschen. Der fragte uns nämlich, wie wir denn das so meinen würden und wie wir denn das so bewerten, dieses Ding mit dem Clean Install. Denn der würde ja mit Logic arbeiten, auf dem iMac und habe wohl gehört, dass das ja eine tolle Sache sein soll.
Naja, es ist die aller tollste Sache.
Macht aber viel Arbeit.
Macht aber viel Arbeit und vor allem, wenn man halt ein System hat, was funktioniert und ich meine, das Apple-Update kommt jetzt einmal im Jahr, wo man oben drüber ansittelt, wenn man halt ein gutes Bauchgefühl hat und man weiß, der Rechner lief immer stabil, hat keinen Ärger gemacht, ist alles okay, ich habe nicht allzu viel rumgefummelt, was ja demnächst dann auch nicht mehr geht, weil ist alles restricted. Oder andere Tools, die da in Ordnern rumfummeln, wo sie eigentlich nichts zu suchen haben oder irgendwelche Packet-Manager, die nach Slash opten und weiß nicht, was man da alles sich verkonfigurieren kann und irgendwie Lips irgendwo hinschiebt, obwohl da eigentlich andere liegen sollten und so weiter und so fort. Leute sich ihr Python updaten und dann wundern, warum bestimmte Sachen nicht mehr gehen. Wenn man das alles nicht hat, dann ist oben drüber installieren voll okay. Wenn man das aber macht und man merkt, das System tut irgendwie gerade nicht mehr so richtig, dann ab und zu muss man dann mal Clean-Install machen.
Ja, aber Clean-Install ist hart mittlerweile.
Man hat zu tun, aber das ist auch ein gutes Gefühl, weil es einfach, kannst du mir erzählen, was du willst, aber der riecht doch noch schneller. Die Wits sind wieder sauber frisch geschrieben, das liest sich einfach besser von der Platte. Irgendwas muss es sein, weil es ist einfach immer...
Nee, das ist mit Sicherheit so, weil Clean-Install ja auch bedeutet, dass man irgendwie nicht hier noch da ein Plug-In, was noch automatisch immer wieder mitgeladen wird.
Genau, der ganze alte Scheiß.
Ja, man installiert Dinge nicht neu, die man nicht noch mal installieren würde, aber auch gar nicht richtig deinstalliert bekommt.
Ja, irgendwelche Google-Apps, Deamon, Flash, der ganze Dreck, der halt noch so rumliegt. Aber es ist halt auch so, früher war ein Clean-Install noch eine verhältnismäßig überschaubare Geschichte.
Ja, das geht nicht mehr so einfach, weil da geht's schon mit der Keychain los.
Da geht's mit Keychain los, da geht's mit diesen ganzen Containern los, die die Programme haben.
Denkt an eure Bitcoin-Wallet, wenn ihr eine habt.
Ja, du hast jetzt so gesandboxte Geschichten und in zunehmendem Maße greifen da teilweise auch schon...
Warum ist Sandbox jetzt ein Problem?
Naja, du musst halt aus deinem alten Zustand alles herauspicken, was du eben nicht neu haben willst. Ja, wenn ich halt jetzt, weil das ist ja auch, was weiß ich, Outbank und dann hast du da zehn Konten drin. Wo du immer mühsam in stundenlanger Arbeit diese ganzen AP Keys von PayPal und was muss ich jetzt wo eingeben, damit ich jetzt überhaupt darauf zugreifen kann. Das sind immer so Prozesse, da ist man mal froh, wenn man das irgendwie hinter sich hat. Machst du einen Clean Install und fängst wirklich bei Null an und du hast halt jetzt von deinem Money Money oder Outbank nicht diesen Container rübergenommen, dann startest du das Programm und das Programm sagt ich weiß gar nichts.
Willkommen bei!
Du musst ja erstmal wissen, wo du hinguckst, weil früher lag ja dann alles irgendwie in Library Application Support, Outbanked, aber wenn es halt eine gesendboxte Version aus dem App Store ist, dann liegt es halt in einem Container, das ist wieder dann in Library Containers, der Library Ordner ist sowieso hidden, das heißt da stößt du jetzt erstmal. Der ist jetzt erstmal in einem Default OS nicht zu sehen und wer nicht weiß, dass es den gibt, weiß überhaupt nicht, wo er sich das herholen soll.
Du kennst den Trick, ne? Gehe zu oder go to Menü und dann die Alt-Taste drücken.
Ja, wenn man das weiß. Wenn man weiß, dass da eine verborgene Tür ist, dann fängst du halt an die Wand abzutasten, aber wenn du halt überhaupt nicht weißt, dass hier überhaupt was verborgen sein kann, dann stehst du da halt wie ein Pferd und wunderst dich, wo sind denn jetzt meine Daten hin? Und dann stehst du da halt mit deinem leeren Outbank oder Money-Money und dann darfst du halt erstmal deine PayPal-AP-Keys irgendwie runterkriegen und musst dann irgendwie deutsche Erklärungen durchlesen auf englischen Webseiten oder umgekehrt, wo es halt nicht AP-Key heißt, sondern Schlüssel-Wert-Ausgabe-Einheits-Identitäts-String, bla, auf Seite, unter Menü, hast du nicht gesehen? Und dann kommt dir noch dieses bekloppte PayPal entgegen, was irgendwie so immer so eine Mischung aus, die alte Webseite, die neue Webseite, oh, dieses Feature, das haben wir nur in der alten Webseite. Nö, das haben wir jetzt noch nicht so umgestellt, weil das benutzt ja eigentlich eh kaum einer. So eine Nummer. Google ist auch ganz groß drin. Und den ganzen Scheiß, den hat man halt an der Backe, wenn man einen Clean-Install macht.
Du hast noch mehr an der Backe, ne? Die ganzen Registration-Keys von Software, die du nicht über einen App-Store gekauft hast.
Oder halt auch Sachen, es ist halt auch nicht unbedingt immer alles im Home. Es gibt halt auch so Sachen, die hast du halt in Slash-Library irgendwo drin. Plug-Ins, so systemweite Internet-Plug-Ins, Dictionaries, ich habe zum Beispiel mehrere systemweite Dictionaries, die ich eigentlich auf jedem Rechner haben will und ich kriege das fast kaum synchronisiert. Weil ich benutze das Dictionary-Programm gerne auf Mac. Wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Wörterbuch oder so, keine Ahnung, ich benutze es nicht. Nein, warum sollte ich das tun?
Du bist der größten, großartigsten...
Lexikon heißt es auf Deutsch.
Lexikon, das ist eine der großartigsten Erfindungen des Macs überhaupt. Ever.
Na gut, wenn du so sagst.
Na, Dreifinger-Tap. Du benutzt das nicht? Nee. Was machst du, wenn du auf einer Webseite ein Wort nicht weißt?
Das passiert mir nicht. Ja, okay, weiß ich nicht, was ich dann tue.
Du sagst, fahr hier öffnen, Dict Leo oder irgendwas anderes. Auf jeden Fall erstmal da rein pumpen.
So viel Zeit hab ich nicht.
Oder gleich Wikipedia.
Na, ich nehm drei Finger und tippe auf das Wort.
Ja, bei Apple, die haben da sowieso alles zensiert. Was ich wissen will, haben die nicht.
Wie zensiert? Na, ich hab, ich hab mein Dictionary von DictCC halt im System installiert. Das heißt, ich hab mein Deutsch-Englisch-Lexikon lokal auf dem Rechner. Ich brauch noch nicht mal Internet dafür. Ich bin so cool, oder? Und du kennst mich, Dennis. Du kannst das all deinen Freunden erzählen. Drei Finger tappen. Tell everybody about it. Willst du mal zeigen? Da, da, da, da, da, hier. Spülschrubber, ja? Spülschrubber mit Wechselkopf. Drei Tapps drauf. Oh, hier hab ich das noch gar nicht in Betrieb genommen, seh ich gerade.
Es geht auf meinem Rechner auch schon mit den drei Tapps, nur dass ich deinen Dick Leo noch nicht installiert hab, oder wie?
Kennt er natürlich jetzt nicht, weil ich hier noch keinen deutschen Textinitiativist habe.
Du hast aufs Touchpad dreimal geklickt, oder? Das mit dem Finger. Das meinst du damit?
Nein, drei Finger auf einmal.
Was, wie?
Dreimal tappen oder drei Finger?
Das hat man in der englischen Webseite hier. Da gibt es auch immer so schöne Worte, die man nicht kennt. Und lass mal eins suchen. Ich sag mal ein Wort, was ihr nicht kennt.
Da war grad surveillance, aber das hast du schon weggeblättert.
Nimm doch auch einfach irgendeinen Voice-Over, kannst du mal fragen, was Voice-Over ist.
Oder Arkham Asylum oder nur Asylum.
So, dreimal draufgetippt und dann kommt sofort Wikipedia, Arkham Asylum, The Elizabeth Arkham Asylum for the criminally insane, commonly called Arkham Asylum or simply Arkham. Ich mach einfach, nimm drei Finger, geh auf dieses Touchpad und dann hab ich die fucking Erklärung ohne, dass ich irgendein neues Browserfenster aufmachen muss, irgendeine Webseite laden muss oder irgendwas. Das ist einfach mal großartig. Und wenn du halt noch deine ganzen zusätzlichen Dictionary Plugins installierst, es gibt halt von DickCC welche, die muss man irgendwie suchen. Es gibt deutsche Thesauren. Also es gibt verschiedene. Dictionary Plugins, das geht seit 10.06 oder 10.05 sogar. Und die hab ich halt systemweit drin. Und so kann ich halt auch ohne Internet immer schnell von einem Wort zum anderen kommen, wenn ich halt Wörter suche, Wortspiele mache oder eben einfach mal was nachschlagen will. Und du hast halt eben auch direkt Zugriff auf Wikipedia, ohne jetzt irgendwelche Wikipedia-Seiten aufmachen zu müssen. So, wie sind wir denn überhaupt jetzt hingekommen? Ja, aber wie sind wir da hingekommen?
Ja, ich wusste über Dinge, die man beim Clean Install umziehen muss.
Ach, Clean Install, genau, wir waren ja eigentlich beim Clean Install. Genau, also Dictionary Plugins ist auch noch so ein Beispiel. Also halt so Zeug, der in Slash Library herumliegt, etc., Sprich, wenn man Clean Install macht und man geht davon aus, dass man möglichst oder man möchte gerne möglichst viel der alten Daten mitnehmen, also Einstellungen der Programme, dann wird es schwierig mit dem Clean Install. Wenn man aber sagt, ich mache jetzt so einen super Clean Install im Sinne von Platte leer, Betriebssystem frisch einspielen und dann alle Programme, die ich benutze, einzeln installieren und mich mit jedem Programm eine halbe Stunde rumschlagen und manuell in allen Settings und Preference Pains und Pipapo und installierten Zusatzfonds und Themes und meine Kino Themes und meine hast-nicht-gesehen-da und meine Fonds, die ich noch im System haben will. Wenn man das halt alles wieder installieren muss. Also ich glaube, ich wäre mit einem Clean Install, bis ich wieder da bin, wo ich jetzt bin, keine Ahnung, bestimmt vier Wochen beschäftigt.
Vier Wochen?
Na klar, du musst dir ja überhaupt erst mal dran erinnern, was du irgendwie vorher gehabt hast.
Na das macht man im Augenblick, wo man es braucht.
Na eigentlich müsste man das mit zwei Rechnern machen.
Also erinnern ist ja schlecht, weil ich will mich ja nicht erinnern, sondern ich will es brauchen.
Ja, du brauchst es aber nicht unbedingt sofort. Manchmal rufst du halt so ein Programm auf und dann wird dir überhaupt erst klar, was du da eigentlich alles...
Aber ich will mich ja nicht erinnern und Sachen installieren, die ich dann eventuell doch irgendwie nicht brauche.
Kann ja mal so ein bisschen durchschauen. Also ich müsste meinen One-Passwort-Kram hier aufsetzen. Treiber für diverse Hardware. Dann hast du hier, keine Ahnung...
Man könnte es natürlich auch so halb easy machen und so ein bisschen schummeln. Das heißt, das System wird komplett neu installiert, aber seinen Home schiebt man einfach komplett rüber.
Ja, aber das ist halt nicht so richtig clean.
Ja, aber das System ist dann schon mal clean.
Das stimmt.
Weil das ist ja meistens da, wo der Ärger herkommt. Ob in meinem Home irgendwie Schrott rumliegt, das ist nicht ganz so schlimm.
Aber das könnte sich ja jetzt ändern mit Capitano. Weil da kann halt keiner, kann nicht so ein Düsseliger USB-UMTS-Stick daherkommen und sagen, ich installiere jetzt mal hier meine Kröten-Treiber in deinem scheiß System. Die laufen zwar im nächsten Update nicht mal ordentlich, aber scheiß drauf, ist mir eh egal. Das passiert halt nicht mehr so ohne mal.
Naja, aber das ist eigentlich nicht das, was ich als größtes Problem habe, sondern das sind eher diese Background-Programme, die dann plötzlich irgendwie dauerhaft 30% CPU-Last fahren.
Ja, da sind diese UMTS-Sticks ja auch ganz groß.
Naja, aber solche Sachen sind nicht unbedingt in Slash-System drin.
Ja, wenn die in deinem Home sind, kannst du sie aber auch easy ausschalten, weil meistens sind die schon irgendwo, wo sie gar nichts zu suchen haben.
Ja gut, ich meine, wenn sie sich in Slash-Library installieren, dann sind sie natürlich dann trotzdem...
Aber da gehören sie ja auch in. Slash-Library, Slash-Startup-System oder Startup-Icons.
Ja gut, wenn du die Frage machst, dann Clean and Install, sind die halt alle weg. Dann startest du, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel, das hab ich jetzt schon lange nicht mehr, wenn du so Photoshop hast, also diese ganze Creative Suite, die last time I checked installiert dir halt auch so eine Myriade von Files in Slash-Library, hast du nicht gesehen.
Ja, aber Photoshop installierst du dann halt neu. So, musst du ja eh. Dann sind die wieder da. Das Problem ist ja nicht, was man nach dem Neuinstallieren wieder da hat, sondern dass man seine Einstellungen auch behält.
Ja gut, aber du musst halt alle Programme neu installieren und das kann dauern. Also so viel zum Thema Clemens soll man nur machen.
Auf der anderen Seite finde ich das immer ganz schön, wenn man es dann macht, weil man muss oder aus anderen Gründen, dann merkt man halt doch relativ schnell, welche Sachen installiere ich nicht nochmal, weil ich sie nicht vermisse, wenn sie nicht installiert sind. Also der Prozess, da fallen dann schon Sachen hinten runter.
Ja gut, aber du weißt es halt erst nach vier Wochen.
Ja, aber gerade wenn du dann im App Store guckst, was du alles installieren könntest und wo du dir denkst, nee, auf den Button drücke ich jetzt nicht. Also ja, ich weiß, ich habe dieses Programm mal gekauft, aber ich will es jetzt nicht in meiner schönen neuen, clean installierten Version wieder haben, weil ich habe das das letzte halbe Jahr nicht benutzt und ich werde es auch das nächste halbe Jahr nicht benutzen.
Ja, aber wenn es dein Wi-Fi Scanner ist, den du jetzt mal brauchst, um überhaupt Internet zu bekommen, den du aber nicht installieren kannst ohne Internet. Naja, ist mir alles schon passiert. Gut, ich denke mal, das dürfte die Frage nach dem Clean Install zumindest umfassend...
Wir haben mal drüber geredet.
Genau, wir haben da mal drüber geredet.
Wir bräuchten dann spezifischere Fragen.
Die Antwort ist also Depends.
Dann hatten wir noch Feedback zum Thema. Wozu eigentlich? Haben wir uns irgendwie über...
Gut, haben wir darüber geredet?
Auch?
Wir hatten ein bisschen Feedback zum Thema Bitcode und es stellt sich halt heraus, dass Chris Lettner doch recht hatte. Wer hätte es gedacht? Also wenn das Compiler Frontend fertig ist mit Kompilieren, dann ist das, was in Bitcode vorliegt, schon relativ nah an die...
Also wir reden jetzt über LLVM, Bitcode und diesen ganzen Spaß mit Programme müssen demnächst nicht fertig durchkompilert werden, sondern liegen so ein bisschen vorgekoid rum.
Also müssen für WatchApp können für iOS. Also das Ding ist, wenn die einmal in Bitcode fertig kompiliert sind, dann sind sie relativ nahe an die Prozessor-Architektur herankompiliert, auch das, was in Bitcode vorliegt. Und jetzt mal so eben ein für ARM kompiliertes Bitcode-Programm auf x86 umkompilieren ist halt nicht. Das war jetzt so der Tenor, da haben wir uns zu weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt. Allerdings die eine oder andere Prozessorinstruktion, mal zu optimieren, dafür könnte es dann doch noch reichen. So war, glaube ich, der Konsens des Feedbacks. Ja, das war's dann, oder? Damit ist das durch.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was da noch... Es wurde noch darauf Bezug genommen, dass ja vor allem diese ABIs, also die Application Binary Interfaces, an der Stelle primär eine Rolle spielen, dass quasi es relevant ist, für welches ABI-Code erzeugt wird und dass das im Wesentlichen die Abhängigkeit erzeugt.
Ja, aber die ABIs unterscheiden sich halt sowohl von System, also Betriebssystem zu Betriebssystem, als auch von Prozessorarchitektur zu Prozessorarchitektur. Aber das ist jetzt auch nichts anderes, als was ich gesagt habe, das ABI ist relativ fest schon vorgegeben, wenn das Frontend fertig ist. Und man kann jetzt nicht plötzlich auf ein anderes ABI kompilieren, wenn man nur den Bitcode für ein ABI hat. Also das war so das Feedback, was wir da hatten.
Genau. Also wir werden sehen.
Wir werden sehen.
Letztendlich ist es nicht die Revolution, aber es verhindert sie auch nicht. Das ist ja schon mal ganz gut.
Na ja, für eine ganz bestimmte Anwendungsfall sprich, den zukünftigen Prozessor optimieren, der da kommen wird, besonders für Watch. Für die Watch ist es wahrscheinlich genau das richtige Mittel der Wahl. Na ja, man wird sehen.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen. So, jetzt kommt ganz viel TLS. Es gab so ein kleines Feedback, dass ja irgendjemand war total entsetzt darüber, dass wir ja tatsächlich es wagen, auf Mac Safari zu benutzen. Weil er wäre ja total unsicher. Uns geht ja gar nicht. Beleg ist, dass man Safari, wenn man auf house, myssl.com liefert, da steht, es wäre ja bad. Das stimmt auch. house.myssl.com ist eine Webseite, die so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen, schlechte Angebote macht an Browser. Und wenn diese Browser sie eingehen, dann führt das zur Abwertung. Und werden halt alle möglichen Key-Exchange-Mechanismen und sonstige Optionen von TLS Transport gecheckt. Kannte ich noch nicht die Webseite, oder vielleicht kannte ich sie, aber hab sie irgendwie nicht so richtig mir gemerkt. Und bei Safari wird da ordentlich gemeckert über insecure Cypher-Suits. Sprich, verschiedene Kombinationen aus Hashing, Krypto, Algorithmen und Key-Längen.
Ja, im Prinzip alles, wo RC4 drin ist.
Genau, im Wesentlichen alles, wo RC4 drin ist. Zumindest bei dem Safari 6, den ich jetzt hier gerade teste. Safari 6? Entschuldigung, Safari 8. Und der Safari 9, der ja jetzt beim Kapitän ausgeliefert wird, der hat nicht so eine ganz so lange Liste von insecure Cypher-Suits, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen, meint Apple, müssten sie noch irgendwas mit RC4 da drin behalten. Warum auch immer? Also ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig, zumal sie ja nun auf der WWDC so ordentlich rum überventiliert haben, wie sicher doch jetzt alles werden muss.
Auf die Kacke gehauen, würde ich sogar sagen.
Auf die Kacke gehauen haben sie. Aber richtig.
Na gut, man kann sich auf das Argument zurückziehen, ist jetzt noch keine fertige Version, sondern nur eine Beta, aber das ist eigentlich auch kein ordentliches Argument.
Ja gut, aber sie sind ja mit ihrem Safari schon in der fertigen Version da draußen und was sie ja im Prinzip sagen ist, sie wollen auf den Zugriff auf bestimmte Webseiten, die Ansecure Ciphers anbieten, noch zugreifen können.
Jetzt wäre interessant zu erfahren, welches diese Webseiten sind, weil das muss ja ein gewichtiges Argument für Apple sein, diese Webseiten zu unterstützen.
Genau, und wenn man halt jetzt mal Firefox oder Chrome mit demselben Test startet, ich tue das mal hier, um ganz aktuelle Ergebnisse zu erzielen, obwohl man Firefox bestimmt wieder outdated ist. Der lädt auch bestimmt schon eine neue Version runter.
Oh, der ist auch bad.
Ja, der ist aber auch nicht...
Das ist aber auch fies, irgendwie Zugänge, die gingen auch, wenn sie vielleicht kriptomäßig nicht mehr so gut funktionieren, vielleicht zu irgendwelchen Devices, wo man das auch nicht so einfach ändern kann und plötzlich kannst du da nicht mehr darauf zugreifen. Das ist schon ein bisschen übel.
So, jetzt mal die Version, die du da hast. Was steht denn da jetzt unter? Was ist denn da jetzt bad bei dem Firefox?
Ich weiß gar nicht, welche Version ist das jetzt? 35, aber die ist bestimmt nicht mehr aktuell.
Naja, aber es wäre jetzt mal interessant, die Version, die du jetzt hast.
Was da angemeckert wird.
Da werden nämlich auch die RC4-Dinger angemeckert.
Aber nur 4 und nicht 6.
Nur 4 und nicht 6.
So, dann starte ich mal den Firefox.
Neu.
Was haben wir jetzt für eine Version? Was ist gerade so angesagt bei Föchstchen? 39.
39. Jetzt ist gut.
Jetzt ist alles supi, genau. Also mit anderen Worten, Firefox haut alles raus und ähnlich. Das ist probably okay, genau. Man soll sich ja nicht zu sehr festlegen. Und was vergleicht man heutzutage noch? Man vergleicht natürlich Chrome. Und mit Chrome, wer das ja nicht borsiert. Und bei Chrome ist auch alles grün. Und bei Safari ist nicht grün.
Ja, aber dieses, das RC4 jetzt plötzlich. Na, was heißt plötzlich, dass RC4 relativ unsicher ist, ist jetzt eine Erkenntnis von wann? Also, dass es richtig unsicher ist. Oder da war doch so ein Paper, was du vorhin...
Na ja, es gab jetzt eine ganze Kaskade von RC4-Vernichtungen. Also, dass es so grundsätzlich schon mal angreifbar ist, das ist schon wohl länger bekannt. Und wenn ich das richtig... also, mich hat das jetzt sozusagen erst heute oder gestern sogar erreicht, gibt es jetzt wohl noch mal ein ganz neues, einen ganz neuen Angriffsvektor. Wo habe ich das hier? rc4nomore.com. Vielleicht ist es auch schon ein paar Tage alt, aber ich glaube, das ist von diesem Jahr auf jeden Fall. Also sie berichten, also sie schreiben hier schön, aber sie sagen halt irgendwie, es sind halt kein Datum, wann sie ihren Artikel hier geschrieben haben, deswegen bin ich da jetzt gerade ein wenig unklar, aber sie berichten halt, dass sie das Paper auf der Usenix Security Konferenz 15 präsentieren wollen und die wollen das Paper noch präsentieren. Genau und die ist im August, im 12.
August, also das ist sozusagen, ungefähr da, wo es Camp ist.
Hot!
Ja, okay, also man könnte jetzt argumentieren, dass der allerneueste Break ist jetzt so jung, dass man Apple noch mal zwei, drei Wochen gönnen könnte und dann müssten sie es aber...
Nee, also RC4, es gab jetzt schon so viele Angriffsviktoren auf RC4, RC4 ist einfach durch. Der hier ist nur noch mehr on the fly, noch schneller, noch mehr. Also hier...
Noch durcher.
Ich hab's mir jetzt im Einzelnen nicht angeschaut, aber es ist so, dass sie alles, was irgendwie halbwegs repetitiv ist, in Verbindungen komplett decryptet bekommen. Ihr Beispiel sind hier Web-Cookies. Von denen sie halt wissen, dass sie da sind und welche Struktur sie haben, etc. Und die kriegen sie wohl irgendwie in 52 Stunden komplett aufgemacht. Nur weil da halt RC4 dabei ist.
Also RC4 ist ja der Vorgänger, haha, von RC5. RC5 ist der Vorgänger von RC6. Und RC6 war, glaube ich, ein Mitbewerber zu dem Advanced Encryption-Standard, der dann dieses Rhinendall geworden ist. Und das ist da auch schon wieder. Wie viele Jahre her? Also RC4 ist wirklich uralt. Ja, weil RC5 schon uralt ist. Ja, genau so.
Das ist wirklich uralt, also zumindest in dem Business.
Das heißt, das ist, ich weiß nicht, warum sie es überhaupt noch irgendwie ins SSL, TLS vorgenommen haben.
Es gibt ja einen RFC 7465, ein RFC, was den Einsatz von RC4 in TLS verbietet. Also es gibt mittlerweile einen RFC, was explizit eine Technologie outlort. Das ist auch neu, das gab es in dem Sinne noch nicht.
Ich glaube, ich sprach mal öfter hier.
RC4, ja genau für Flash, da kommen wir auch noch gleich noch dazu.
Das schreib ich morgen.
Also Februar 2015 gibt es diesen RFC. Ich meine, gut, RFC ist ein RFC, das kann man auch ignorieren, aber sollte man vielleicht nicht. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum Apple das noch nicht rausgenommen hat. Kann ich nicht erklären.
Ja, No More steht für Numerous Occurrence Monitoring and Recovery Exploit, ne? Super. Ich liebe diese Abkürzungen.
So, aber in der Hinsicht haben wir ja noch mehr zu berichten. Nämlich, nicht zueinander bringen.
Wo ist denn deine schicke, lange Trennungslinie, die dir sonst einmal einen Unterschied gibt?
Ich bin hier mittlerweile komplett verloren. Ich muss zu viele Dinge gleichzeitig machen. Ich mach das aber gleich noch ordentlich. Und zwar, weil das nämlich hier alles mit reingehört. Und zwar geht es jetzt mal um Podcasts, weil das ist ja ein Thema, das kommt ja hier relativ selten zur Sprache. Und vollkommen nachvollziehbar wird mir ja von der Gemeinde, der Community, vorgeworfen, dass ich ja überhaupt nicht befugt und berechtigt bin, das Wort Therese auch nur in den Mund zu nehmen, wo ich doch mit der Metaebene garstigerweise nicht einen einzigen Podcast per HTTPS und das Volk bringe. Nicht, dass das irgendwie besonders viele andere Podcasts tun würden, aber naja, wie das nun mal so ist.
Was ist denn da so eine Ausrede?
Naja, ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie der Letzte bin, der da nachzieht, sondern es gibt halt fast überhaupt keine Podcasts.
Du hast da Vorreiter-Positionen oder Beanspruchst du die zumindest? Absolut.
Ich hab auch überhaupt nichts dagegen, ganz vorne mitzuschwimmen, nur ist es halt nicht einfach. Und ich habe jetzt in den letzten Tagen und Wochen mal genau zusammengetragen, was eigentlich das Problem ist. Weil ich das ehrlich gesagt bisher auch immer nur partiell verstanden habe und so eine Andeutung mich ergangen habe. Deswegen wollte ich jetzt nochmal kurz erklären, warum die Metaebene kein HTTPS hat.
Schuld sind immer die anderen.
Auch. Also abgesehen von so WordPress-Problemen, die man hat, wenn man jetzt WordPress mit mehreren unterschiedlichen Domains benutzt und eine Installation, dann hat man da so ein komisches Plugin, was dann die Domains irgendwie hin und her jongliert. Und es ist dann immer ein bisschen unklar, welche URL-Basis jetzt an welches Modul, an welcher Stelle durchgereicht wird, weil WordPress, weil es irgendwie intern vier oder fünf verschiedene Variablen gibt, die irgendwie Site-URL und Home-URL und hast-du-nicht-gesehen-URL heißen und es vollkommen unklar ist, wer jetzt wem was gibt, so dass jede Änderung an der Stelle das Haus sehr schnell zum Einstürzen bringt. Und man auch noch das Problem hat, dass man eben den Admin-Bereich natürlich per HTTPS schützen möchte, aber das WordPress es einem nicht einfach macht, das auch separat zu behandeln. Die eigentliche Frage ist, warum sind die ganzen Public-Inhalte nicht über HTTPS, sondern per HTTPS. Schauen wir uns an, was man bräuchte, um HTTPS zu machen. Da hat also die Webseite und ignorieren wir jetzt erstmal die Mittebene. Gehen wir jetzt einfach mal von irgendwie myownpodcast.com aus. Und ich will das jetzt von HTTP auf HTTPS machen. Dann gehen wir erstmal zu einem Zertifikats-ausgebenden Institut und sagt Hallo, guten Tag, ich habe entweder viel Geld oder auch nicht. Und ich hätte jetzt gerne mal ein Zertifikat. Dann bekommt man das irgendwie ausgestellt. Dann muss man das installieren. Der Web-Server präsentiert das allen Vorbeibrausenden. Und man stellt sich da natürlich auch noch die Frage, ist das nun eine Option oder will man das sozusagen nur machen? Also hat man HTTP und HTTPS gleichzeitig? Könnte man ja sagen, ist ja eigentlich egal. Könnte aber auch sagen, wenn man jetzt eh HTTPS macht, warum sollte man dann überhaupt noch HTTP machen? Ein Problem jetzt spezifisch bei Podcastern ist in dem Moment, wo ich halt einen Feed rausgebe in Verzeichnisse, dann ist das natürlich ein anderer Feed mit einem S in dem HTTP als ohne. Das heißt, mache ich sowohl HTTP als auch HTTPS, habe ich halt unter Umständen das Problem, dass ich in den Verzeichnissen gedoppelt werde, doppelt gefunden werde. Nee, so cool ist das halt irgendwie nicht, weil dann ist die Beschreibung alles. Also Leute treffen auf deinen Kram, es ist doppelt, dann was weiß ich, dann filtern vielleicht irgendwelche Verzeichnisse das aber auch wieder raus und nehmen dann irgendwie das HTTPS raus, etc. Also das ist sozusagen schon etwas, worum man sich Gedanken machen soll und grundsätzlich kann ich eigentlich allen Leuten, die einen Podcast machen, nur raten HTTPS oder HTTPS, aber auf gar keinen Fall beides. Also das ist sozusagen, wenn muss man sich schon irgendwie für das eine oder das andere entscheiden. Und jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, okay, dann mach ich einfach HTTPS. Hol mir irgendwie das geilste Zertifikat, was man kriegen kann, damit danach die ganzen Hörer, nachdem man verkündet hat, dass man jetzt HTTPS hat, weil dann gehen die ja alle zu SSL Labs, zum SSL-Test und sagen, ach, guck mal, was der jetzt hier für ein Grade hat. Und dann wird halt irgendwie der Test durchgefahren. Und wenn da halt nicht irgendwie so ein grün schimmerndes, dickes, fettes A-Plus ist, dann ist man ja sowieso scheiße und kann gleich wieder zum Anfang gehen und so weiter. Klingt ja jetzt auch erstmal alles sehr einfach. Zertifikat holen, Zertifikat installieren, alles auf HTTPS-Only umstellen, ordentliche Redirects machen, also schon auf HTTPS Antworten. Man soll ja nicht HTTPS ausschalten, sondern muss auf HTTPS antworten und permanent Redirects rausgeben, also 301 HTTPS-Codes, die dann halt von HTTPS dieselbe URL auf HTTPS umsetzen und nicht nur auf die Homepage umleiten, sondern sozusagen die URL beibehalten und aus dem HTTPS ein HTTPS machen, weil dann müsste ja alles, was dann irgendwie noch über HTTPS kommt, im Prinzip auf HTTPS gebracht werden und dann fangen die Vögle an zu switchern und die Sonne geht auf und es ist irgendwie schön und gebratene Hähnchen fliegen durch die Luft. Aber! Aber! Hier beginnt schon mal Problem 1. Wenn ich nämlich jetzt ein geiles Zertifikat mache, was irgendwie bei den SSL-Labs ein A kriegt und grün leuchtet und nicht irgendwie so ein schmieriges B oder so ein ranziges C, heißt das, dass ich diese ganzen bösen Cipher, RC4 und diesen ganzen Climpim, ausgeschaltet habe. Dann allerdings kommen so kluge Betriebssystem-Dinge, die immer noch da draußen herumgurken, wie zum Beispiel Android 2.3-Versionen, die natürlich kein Mensch mehr wirklich noch benutzt, weil das ist ja alt, aber wir wissen. Es gibt sicherlich auch noch weitere Beispiele. Ich kann jetzt keine nennen. Mir geht es jetzt auch nicht konkret um Android. Ich werde vielleicht noch ein anderes schönes, viel überzeugenderes Beispiel nennen, was an der Stelle kaputt ist. Aber das ist zum Beispiel so ein Ding. Also es gibt verschiedene Subsysteme, Apps, Frameworks, die schlicht und eingreifend dann sagen, ich kann mich damit nicht connecten, weil Fehler beim SSL-Aufbau, weil ich will nämlich hier einen kaputten Cipher haben und der kaputte Cipher wird nicht unterstützt und man fliegt halt raus. Mit anderen Worten, man muss darauf vorbereitet sein, dass wenn man auf HTTPS umstellt, einen gewissen Teil seiner Bezieher unter Umständen verliert. Womit ich persönlich auch ehrlich gesagt gar kein Problem hätte. Also wenn das so drei Prozent sind, die jetzt mit altem Scheiß arbeiten und mit so Clients, von denen noch nie einer gehört hat und keine Ahnung, so ein Blackberry Podcast Client, der den Namen nicht verdient und irgendeine SSL Library von vor Hallo Dunemals benutzt, dann ist mir das wirklich egal. Aber was ich natürlich nicht will, ist, dass irgendwie ein Großteil herausfliegt. Stellt sich aber heraus, alle modernen Podcast Clients, vor allem so unter iOS, alles total unproblematisch, auch mit den neueren Android Versionen, alles total unproblematisch, alles ist gut für kleine Zwitschern, alles ist toll.
Aber... Ach, immer noch keine Sonne.
Naja, das ist jetzt tatsächlich, sagen wir mal, eine Lösung für den Teil mit ich biete meine Webseite, meine eine Webseite mit meinem einen Podcast an. Und ich will, dass die Podcast Clients drauf zugreifen können. Das würde tatsächlich funktionieren. Aber das Problem ist...
Auch ein Problem.
Es sind ja nicht nur Podcast Clients, die auf den Podcast zugreifen, die wichtig sind. Sondern es gibt ja auch noch Podcast Verzeichnisse, die auf den eigenen Podcast zugreifen, um regelmäßig den Feed auszulesen, um zu sehen, wo neue Episoden sind. Und vor allem, die dafür sorgen, dass man ja gefunden wird. Allen voran das iTunes Podcast Directory von Apple. Was ja leider einen so wichtigen Stellenwert hat, dass es sozusagen die Quelle ist. Also wenn man nicht in iTunes ist, wie es so schön heißt, dann ist man ja irgendwie nicht da. Das ist ja sozusagen das Google Podcast. Was da nicht gefunden wird, existiert irgendwie nicht. Das ist halt einfach so. Auch weil viele Podcast-Klans eben darauf zurückgreifen, um überhaupt zu suchen, wenn sie einen Podcast nicht selber haben. Das ist sozusagen der Ort, wo man eben nachschaut. Weil aus Google kriegt man diese Informationen nicht raus, weil es gibt da kein Podcast Verzeichnis. Also muss iTunes irgendwie einen auch scannen. Und wenn man halt jetzt HTTPS hat und man hat sich so ein supergeiles, scharfes, geiles, Android 2.3-verachtendes Zert mit ohne RC4 geholt, dann sagt halt iTunes, geht nicht.
Also was folgern wir daraus? Warum? Apple iTunes läuft unter Android 2.3?
Nein, oder Java 6. Das ist nämlich diese alte Web-Objects-Scheiße, wo sie ja mal in einem Moment der geistigen Umnachtung irgendwann mal ihre Web-Objects komplett von Objectives, die auf Java portiert haben und da bis heute im heutigen Tage irgendwie nicht wieder von weggekommen sind. Ist geil, oder? Und noch viel schlimmer, es basiert halt auf Java 6, auch heute noch. As we speak läuft diese iTunes. Podcast Directory Grabber läuft in Java 6. Was zwei interessante Effekte hat. Nämlich erstens, du musst ein schlechtes Zertifikat haben und alte Cipher unterstützen. Bestimmte, oder einen mindestens, damit das geht. Wenn du halt so ein Start SSL Super Shiny Turbo Plus Ah Great Zertifikat hast, dann wirst du halt von iTunes einfach rausgekickt. Weil Fehler, Error. Es gab ein Problem mit ihrem Feed, tut uns leid. Wir antworten in drei Wochen auf ihre Mail vielleicht und schicken ihnen dann einen anderen Textbaustein, mit dem sie unglücklich sind.
Okay, laut Wikipedias Java 6 vom 11. Dezember 2006. Das ist schon bitter.
Das ist bitter, aber es kommt noch schlimmer.
Schlimmer geht immer.
Denn, jetzt könnte ich ja sagen, scheiß drauf, lieber HTTPS und diesen einen Cipher, wo irgendwie sogar das coole neue Safari in El Capitan irgendwie noch ein Auge zudrückt und es mag dann vielleicht nicht NSA-gehärtet sein, aber zumindest brauche ich jetzt nicht einfach mal meinen Koksröhrchen aufs Internetkabel legen und ich kann mir da irgendwie die Passwörter im Direktzugriff rausschnorcheln. Nein, es ist noch schlimmer, weil wenn ich das nämlich jetzt mit der Metaebene machen wollen würde, habe ich das Problem, dass ich natürlich nicht nur gezwungen bin, überhaupt HTTP-Zugänge anzubieten, damit man da überhaupt erst mal hinkommt, sondern ich muss ja auch noch IPv4 anbieten. Weil IPv4 befindet sich ja nach wie vor in Benutzung, wie wir ja wissen. Leute sind mit Computern unterwegs, die nur V4-Adressen erhalten und die nur V4-Kommunikation machen. Das wird sich irgendwann mal ändern, aber so weit sind wir ja noch nicht. Weil ich aber meinen Server über V4 anbieten muss. Ich aber mehrere Domains habe, nämlich ganz ganz ganz ganz viele, mindestens so 12 oder 13, die ich ja alle über HTTPS sichern möchte, aber alle über dieselbe IP-Adresse kommen, muss ich ja mehrere Zertifikate über dieselbe IP-Adresse anbieten. Und da ich halt nicht wie beim normalen HTTP so ein Virtual-Domain Schnick Schnack machen kann, sondern quasi direkt auf den Kontakt ja mit Zertifikaten anfangen, überhaupt erstmal eine Verbindung auszuhandeln, muss ich ein Zertifikat präsentieren, in dem halt alle Zertifikate drin sind, die ich hier im Angebot habe. Ein sogenanntes SNI. SNI, wir schlagen nach, heißt Server Name Indication und ist diese Erweiterung von TLS, wo man halt sagen kann, unter dieser IP-Adresse sind halt mehrere SSL-Seiten zu erreichen, die halt unterschiedliche Domains haben. Welche meinst du denn jetzt? Ah ja, die, okay, das ist das Zertifikat. Das heißt, du hast sozusagen mehrere Zertifikate in einem. Und wer kann das nicht? Java 6. Und wer war noch gleich in Java 6 geschrieben? Das iTunes Podcast Directory. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt halt anfangen würde, meinen Kram anzubieten und den ich halt auch über V4 anbieten muss, muss ich SNI benutzen und wenn ich SNI benutze, habe ich bei iTunes einfach überhaupt keine Chance. Oder anders ausgedrückt, ich kann kein HTTPS anbieten, weil sonst fliege ich aus dem iTunes-Verzeichnis. Fliege ich aus dem iTunes-Verzeichnis, fliege ich aus allen Podcast-Client. Will ich das? Nee.
Eher nicht.
Wäre das zumutbar? Nicht wirklich. Und das ist halt der Scheißdreck, der da gerade irgendwie ist. Mit anderen Worten Apple. Die Penner, die auf ihrer Scheiß-WWDC irgendwie allen App-Developern gerade einen Einlauf geben. Warum sie denn bitte irgendwie HTTP verwenden? Und sie sollten doch mal hier dieses geile Framework was defaultet auf TLS 1, 2 und den neuesten heißen Scheiß. Ja, warum sie denn das nicht bitte benutzen und wenn ihr das nicht macht, dann kommt ihr nicht in den fucking App-Store. Dieses Unternehmen leistet sich ein Podcast-Verzeichnis, was irgendwie das Web abgrast. Mit so einer uralten Rotten Software, die zehn Jahre alt ist und security-mäßig komplett out of date. Da steht sogar irgendwo in ihrer FAQ drin. Ja, du hast ja ein Problem mit dem Einreichen, da musst du halt irgendwas nehmen, was Java 6 kompatibel ist, weil sonst geht's nicht. Was übrigens auch heißt, du musst halt auch eine CA nehmen, die in Java 6 als Trusted Roots CA eingetragen ist. Wenn du also irgendeine neuere CA nimmst, die seitdem erst das Licht der Welt erblickt hat und die total cool ist, die aber in irgendeiner Form aus Gründen nicht in die Zeit zu Java 6 zurückgebeamt werden kann, dann geht das halt auch nicht. Das ist richtig, richtig geil. Und dann hat mich natürlich noch interessiert, ob auch Let's Encrypt davon betroffen ist, weil das wäre natürlich sozusagen das System meiner Wahl, dass ich, wenn jetzt im September Let's Encrypt angeschaltet wird, dann hätte man halt mal Zertifikate für alle seine Webseiten, mal so eben zack bumm fertig mit irgendeinem Skript.
Natürlich.
Ist in Java 6 abgedeckt, weil dieses IdentTrust-CA, wo die sich ja drunter hängen, da schon drin war. Also das Problem besteht nicht. Aber es besteht das Problem mit SNI und es besteht das Problem mit dem kaputten Cipher. Aber das Hauptproblem ist halt SNI und da komme ich halt nicht dran vorbei. Das heißt, solange iTunes nicht ihren Java 6 Scheiß wegschmeißt und mindestens auf Java 7 geht oder vielleicht auf Swift oder auf irgendwas Sinnvolles, meinetwegen sollen sie diesen Go-Nope rühren, mir ist es egal. Es geht ja auch nur um ihren Scheiß-Crawler. Ich meine, die ganzen anderen Scheiß können sie ja damit machen, aber warum crawlen sie mit so einem Kack? Penner.
Ja, dieses Web-Objects wird das eigentlich überhaupt noch von Apple angeboten. So für...
Nicht wirklich, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob sie das anbieten, aber die benutzen das halt für ihren ganzen Scheiß-Store. Der Apple Store ist halt Web-Objects. Keine Ahnung, ich meine, sie haben ja schon von Zeit zu Zeit mal so den Drei irgendwie alles neu zu machen, aber ich vermute halt, dass irgendwie ihr ganzes iTunes-Connect, Giraffe, App Store, Glimbim, das ganze Warn, dass es auch damit gemacht ist. Ich weiß es aber nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das müssen sie doch auch secure kriegen.
Ja, das müssen sie halt eben. Also sie müssen das halt eigentlich auch alles secure kriegen. Und ich weiß nicht so recht, ja, wie. So viel zum Thema Podcast und HTTPS und warum die Metaebene kein HTTPS hat. Ich würde es ja wirklich gerne tun, aber es geht nicht. Es ist nicht machbar. Es sei denn, ich hole mir für jede meiner Webseiten eine eigene IPv4-Adresse. Aber wie verfügbar IPv4-Adressen sind, wissen wir ja auch. Nicht sehr. Wenn ich jetzt zu meinem Provider gehe und sage, hier gib mir meine IPv4-Adresse für jede meiner stummligen Webseiten, nur damit ich irgendwie das blöde iTunes-Verzeichnis umgehen kann, zeigen die mir auch ein Vogel. Was ist der moderne Goldstaub?
IPv4-Adressen? Nee, will auch keiner mehr haben.
Na, ich schon. Also abgesehen davon, dass... Natürlich will ich da weg, aber wenn ich jetzt V4 abschalte, deswegen... Und ich kann das ja auch nicht selektiv machen, ich kann nicht sagen, ich mach HTTPS über V6 und V4 über HTTPS, dann hab ich ja immer noch zwei URLs da draußen. Will ich aber nicht, will nur eine URL da draußen haben. Und wenn dann halt HTTPS, und wenn ich halt HTTPS mache, dann muss ich es halt entweder nur über V6 machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Apple überhaupt in der Lage ist, mit V6 den Vieh zu ziehen, mit ihrem Java 6. Bestimmt nicht. Also, würde mich jetzt nicht wundern, wenn das auch nicht ginge, ich weiß es aber nicht.
Und wenn ich halt V4 abschalte, ist es dann auch tot, ja.
Das einzige, was man jetzt vielleicht noch machen kann, ist irgendein so ein bekloppten SSL-Proxy davor schalten, der halt nur, wenn iTunes oder irgendeine Apple-10-Punkt- Sternadresse angeschossen kommt und da ein Connect macht, dass man dann halt ein anderes Zertifikat mit RC4 macht und sich da irgendwie eins zurechtlegt für jede.
Lügt.
Irgendwie lügt genau und so was, keine Ahnung, irgendwas.
Kann man sowas nicht mit einem Nginx bauen oder so?
Ja, aber ist das jetzt irgendwie meine Aufgabe? Ich meine, die Konfiguration der Webseite ist jetzt auch schon nicht so mega trivial. Also für einen gestandenen Admin, der nichts anderes macht, ist es vielleicht nicht das Problem, aber es ist irgendwie nicht mein Hauptinteresse, Apple Security-Probleme zu lösen.
Naja, ich meine, man könnte natürlich argumentieren, es sind auch deine Security-Probleme.
Ja, oder ihre, keine Ahnung, also ich meine, you're not helping Apple. Also es ist einfach, das ist einfach, ich meine, was bitte in aller Welt denkt ihr euch dabei? Da wollt ihr ja irgendwie alle, und ich meine, es ist sehr interessant, wenn man jetzt Leute in der Podcast-Szene anschreibt, also Developer, wegen HTTPS, also zum Beispiel gab es, es gibt jetzt, es gibt ja einen Feed-Validator für Podcasts. Also der normale W3C Feed-Validator, der ist ja vollkommen mischiger. Und es gibt einen, der hat sich den genommen, gepatcht und irgendwie besser gehackt. Das Ding heißt Cast Feed-Validator. castfeedvalidator.com. Das ist irgendwie so halbwegs modern gemacht und da checken sie irgendwie ein paar Sachen. Ich bin nicht unbedingt mit allen Entscheidungen da so glücklich, die sie machen, aber das funktioniert eine Million mal besser als alles andere, was ich bisher gesehen habe. Wir wollten bei PodLav ja eigentlich auch schon mal ein Feed-Validator machen, da sind wir nicht so richtig mit vorangekommen, weil das ist halt auch ein ziemlicher Aufwand. Na ja, dann habe ich halt hier auch mal so eine HTTPS-UAL eingegeben und habe festgestellt, dass wenn ich da was mit HTTPS eingebe, dass er mir dann gleich automatisch nochmal ein HTTPS davor knallt. Weil da ist ja kein HTTPS davor. In einigen Worten hat noch nie einer jemals eine HTTPS-Adresse eingegeben von denen oder auch nur als erforderlich erachtet. Dann habe ich denen irgendwie net geschrieben, was denn hier so wäre und worum geht denn bei euch HTTPS, was ich denen meinen würde und dann habe ich ihnen den Bug gezeigt und so. Dann meint er dann ja, warum würdest du denn überhaupt HTTPS machen wollen? Solche Fragen kriege ich oft. Ich meine, ich habe es ihm dann erklärt und habe ihn auch irgendwie eingesehen oder gab zumindest da keine Debatte drum. Aber es gibt halt auch so Podcasts, Kleine Developer, die sehen das halt einfach überhaupt nicht ein. Warum man denn etwas Öffentliches, wie ein Podcast, denn über HTTPS anbieten wollen würde? Wo ich dann halt auch sage, sag mal, habt ihr irgendwie die letzten zwei Jahre unter einem Stein gelebt oder? Oder was? Ja gut, aber mindestens die letzten zwei Jahre. Vermutlich haben sie das auch.
Naja, ich reg mich schon wieder auf.
Das verkürzt meine Lebenszeit.
Zwei Jahre.
Aber auf CarSpendingData, um gleich noch mal dazu zu sagen, kann man jetzt auch HTTPS Feeds checken lassen und das ist schon mal sehr gut.
Also er hat sich dann doch ein Herz genommen und hat das für dich...
Ja, das war halt ein kleiner Bug. Er hatte das halt noch nie getestet und jetzt ist es halt irgendwie drin. Denn irgendwas hat er halt irgendwie richtig gemacht. Jetzt hab ich mich ein bisschen aufgeregt, ist es gut. Jetzt können wir gleich wieder Apple-Produkte loben. Da finden wir ja bekannt.
Klar, wann?
Also ich hab noch einen Eintrag zum Thema HTTPS. Ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal in irgendeinem anderen Podcast zum Besten gegeben. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht. Ich glaube, bei Logbuch Netzpolitik, aber das passt jetzt hier gerade nochmal so schön rein. Weil das nämlich so frech ist. Ich war irgendwie in England an so einer Uni. Und habe da einen Podcast aufgenommen. Und immer wenn ich so einen Podcast aufnehme, dann frage ich halt auch immer nach Internetzugang. Weil ich immer nicht so richtig weiß, ob dann so mein Mobilfunk so richtig funktioniert. Und ich brauche halt während der Sendung irgendwie Netz, um mal eben schnell was nachschlagen zu können. Und das ist immer sehr interessant zu sehen, wie man an so Universitäten Internet bekommt. Also so als Nicht-Member. Und naja, dann geht das halt so verschiedene Wege. Manchmal kriegt man dann so einen Zettel gesteckt. Hier hast du ein Passwort. Oder hier hast du irgendwie deinen komischen Zugang für dein Capture, für unser Capture-Portal. Und manchmal muss man noch tausend Sachen ausfüllen, wenn man denn ist. Und da war das halt so richtig so, ja, hier Fett und wie, schreib mal Adresse rein, bla, bla, bla. Telefonnummer, E-Mail-Adresse, halt so irgendwie England, voll paranoia, Modus on. Ist so okay, scheiß drauf. Wissen sowieso, wer ich bin. Ist jetzt nicht irgendwie der Punkt. Ich will jetzt hier irgendwie nichts haben. Das hab ich alles ausgefüllt. Dann kriegt ich dann halt irgendwie einen Key. Also natürlich Log in und Key, weil warum sollte man nur einen Key eingeben? Das ist ja viel zu unsicher. Nein, es muss so richtig schön schwierig sein. Man muss zwei eingeben. Und naja, dann hatte ich das halt irgendwie. Dann hatte ich irgendwie so WLAN, hatte ich irgendwie ein Netz und das machte auch irgendwie einen schnellen Eindruck. Und dann suchte ich was und löste eine Google-Suche aus. Fehlermeldung. Was, wie, was? Großes SSL-Fenster geht auf. Ja, ungültiges Zertifikat, google.co.uk. Bitte? Was geht denn hier? Schauen wir das an. Und dann stellte ich fest, dass dieses Zertifikat, was mir gerade von google.co.uk präsentiert wurde, nicht von google.co.uk präsentiert wurde, sondern von der Firewall, dieser Uni, die mir halt in mein HTTPS-Verbindung reingegangen ist und eine selbst ausgestellte Zertifikat für google.co.uk präsentierte. Ich glaube, es war sogar sterngoogle.com. Das heißt, sie hatten eine Firewall, die in die HTTPS-Verbindung reingegangen ist. Die kaputt gemacht hat und die sozusagen gesehen hat hier IP-Adresse, da will sich jemand zu Google connecten, sozusagen an der IP-Adresse gesehen hat, da will jemand zu Google und dann halt ein Man-in-the-Middle-Attacker gestartet hat und mir irgendein anderes Zertifikat präsentiert hat, was von ihrer eigenen CA ausgestellt war, was vermutlich auf all diesen installierten Rechnern in der ganzen Uni überall defaultmäßig installiert ist, sodass die Leute, die halt da googeln über HTTPS, weil das ja bei Google mittlerweile default ist, schön abgeschneuchelt werden. Schön abgeschneuchelt wird. Das selbe mit YouTube und ich hab dann nicht so viel Zeit gehabt, jetzt irgendwie das ganze Internet abzuscannen und zu gucken, wo jetzt irgendwie überall so Zertifikate rauskommen. Aber es war mindestens Google und YouTube und vermutlich noch einiges andere mehr. DuckDuckGo war nicht betroffen, das kannten sie wohl noch nicht, keine Ahnung. Von daher war es dann für mich jetzt auch nicht so schwierig. Aber was das halt gezeigt hat, ist einfach, wie frech die sind. Weil ich meine, warum sollte jemand, ich meine, why? Ja, freie Wissenschaft, ne? Wissenschaftler, freies Wissen und so.
Naja, wenn wir ihre Briefe versenden sollen, dann lassen sie sie bitte offen.
Also es ist echt ein Drama. Drama. Sorry, Sorge nur mit SSL und Para. Ich erzähl gleich noch was zu GPG. Aber jetzt darf Dennis erstmal. Genau. Ich hab schon installiert. Hab ich falsch gemacht?
Nee, ist alles super. Möglichst viele Notes, möglichst oft lange laufen lassen. Ja, die Release Notes von Bitcoin 011, müsst ihr euch mal selber durchlesen. Das ist viel zu viel und viel zu lange. Wie wir aber schon irgendwie auch im Twitter nochmal festgestellt haben, dieses Block Pruning, womit die Blockchain, die inzwischen wohl 40 GB groß sein soll, weil ich gucke gar nicht immer so genau nach hier auf meinem Rechner, aber die, um die ein bisschen kleiner zu halten mit dem Pruning, dann kann man seine Wallet nicht benutzen. Also es geht nur, wenn man keine Bitcoins hat. Das ist eigentlich dann nur so ein Service an dem Bitcoin-Ecosystem, aber man kann nicht mehr richtig mitmachen. Man kann nur anderen helfen, die mitmachen. Deswegen würde ich das eigentlich auch nicht empfehlen, aber das ist ein Feature von dem 011. Das wird aber noch besser, sodass es irgendwann auch mit BitWallet geht. Ansonsten würde ich noch kurz ein Feature erklären bei Bitcoin, was bald mal irgendwann kommen wird, weil es hört sich ein bisschen interessant an. Und zwar gibt es jetzt schon ein Feature, mit dem kann man eine Transaktion, wenn man eine macht, für eine gewisse Zeit sperren. Das heißt, du schreibst rein, die soll die nächsten drei Monate nicht ausgeführt werden und schickst die raus. Und bevor die drei Monate nicht um sind, wird die in keinen Block eingebaut und ist somit nicht gültig. Die wird sozusagen nicht gemeint. Du kannst aber in den drei Monaten die trotzdem ausgeben, weil du hast die Bitcoins ja noch, weil die dürfen ja nicht gemeint werden für drei Monate. Du könntest sie dann anders ausgeben, falls sie dich umentscheidet. Aber diese Transaktion würde, wenn du sonst nichts ausgibst, nach drei Monaten ausgeführt werden.
Man kann die auch nicht mehr stornieren, außer man gibt dieselben Bitcoins aus.
Außer du gibst sie aus, genau.
Dieselben Bitcoins?
Deine Bitcoins liegen tatsächlich kryptomäßig auch sozusagen als Coins vor. Du hast dann sozusagen eine 3 Euro Coin und eine 5 Euro. Und wenn du einen ausgibst, dann wird entweder der 5er oder der 3er Coin aufgebrochen und das Wechselgeld wird dir zurück überwiesen. Dann hast du sozusagen, wenn du den 3er aufsplittest, dann einen schiebst du raus und der 2er, der kommt zu dir zurück. So geht das irgendwie. Deswegen, man hat tatsächlich Coins. Das hatte ich bei meinem Bitcoin-Pool mal. Ich hatte mehrere Coins, die immer so ausgegeben wurden. Dann hatte ich irgendwie 6 Überweisungen gleichzeitig laufen und ich hatte bei mir nur gerade 6 Eintel-Coins. Und dann waren die alle aufgesplittet und die Transaktion muss ja erst im Block eingearbeitet werden. Vorher kriegst du dein Wechselgeld nicht zurück. Das heißt, solange ist dein Wechselgeld gesperrt und dann kannst du nicht dein Restgeld schon mal ausgeben, sondern du musst dann erst warten. Und das heißt, die User haben sich beschwert, warum sie ihr Geld nicht kriegen. Und ich hab's auch erst nicht kapiert, bis ich gemerkt hab, ja, meine Coins sind alle in use und ihr müsst immer ein bisschen warten, bis sie wieder frei werden und so.
Was heißt ein bisschen warten eigentlich?
Na, bis die, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es eine Transaktion war oder tatsächlich sechs. Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr so sicher, aber ich glaub mindestens eine. Da bin ich mir aber jetzt nicht so...
Und wie lange dauert das dann in Zeit?
Na, kann man halt nicht so sagen. Im Durchschnitt zehn Minuten. Der Block ist ja immer ca. alle zehn Minuten. Es kann eine halbe Stunde dauern. Es kann theoretisch sonst wie viel Stunden dauern. Ich weiß gar nicht, was der bisherige Rekord ist. Ich glaube so zwei, drei Stunden oder so. Egal, so ein Feature gibt es auf jeden Fall. Es ist nicht so wirklich, wird das benutzt. Aber es gibt jetzt. Überlegen Sie sich für die Zukunft ein neues Feature. Und da wird es wohl spannender. Ich kann es mir noch nicht so richtig erklären, wie man es einsetzen würde. Aber die erzählen da so Sachen, dass dann so Unfälle wie mit Silk Road und so nicht passieren könnten. Nicht so richtig. Also dass das ganze Geld verschwindet. Und zwar wird es...
Sie arbeiten an einem neuen Drogenpool sozusagen.
Ja, nicht ganz. Und zwar gibt es jetzt schon, ist es in dieser Bitcoin Core Wallet, das ist die GUI, die die haben, also Bitcoin Core heißt es ja, stellt das Feature zwar nicht zur Verfügung, aber vom Protokoll her ist es wohl schon geht das. Und zwar heißt das Multisig. Also die ganzen Profi-Bitcoin-Experten würden mir verzeihen und sollen in den Kommentaren schreiben, wenn ich was falsch erklärt hab und hab ich bestimmt, aber so grob müsste das hinhauen. Und zwar mit Multisig kann man machen, dass wir bestimmte Coins nur ausgeben können, wenn wir beide den Key haben. Also wir teilen uns den Key. Also Timme, du und ich, wir könnten irgendwie 100 Bitcoins haben. Und wir könnten so dafür sorgen, dass wir die immer nur zusammen ausgeben. Weil du hast eine Hälfte vom Key und ich habe die andere Hälfte vom Key. Also angenommen, wir hätten jetzt ein Business zum Beispiel, wir wären ein Geschäftspartner.
Schertmanni sozusagen.
Genau, das nennt man Multisig.
Also Multisignature sozusagen.
Ja und das gibt es jetzt auch schon.
Nicht beide den Schlüssel zum Key, sondern der Safe hat zwei Schlösser, die unterschiedlich sind und jeder hat einen Schlüssel.
Das meinte ich auch.
Und beide müssen geschlossen werden.
Da bin ich mir aber auch nicht so sicher, ob die Metapher stimmt. Das könnte nämlich auch sein, dass beide den halben Schlüssel haben und dann nur einschloss ist.
Läuft aufs gleiche raus. Also wenn du nicht beide Schlüssel hast, dann geht halt nichts.
Genau. Und jetzt kommt ein neues Feature. Ich glaube es hieß BIP38. Die haben immer Bitcoin Informational Protocol. Das sind immer so Vorschläge. Proposals? Ja, bei BitTorrent gab es das auch schon immer. Ich glaube BIP38. Da gibt es jedenfalls jetzt ein Feature. Gibt es jetzt ein neues Feature. Und zwar, dass wir jetzt ein Multisig machen, wo wir auch beide wieder nur zugreifen können. Und wir aber schon eine Zeit einstellen, ab wann auch noch ein Dritter zugreifen kann. Das heißt, wir würden uns unsere Bitcoins schützen, sodass wir beide nur die zusammen ausgeben können. Und wenn wir das aber nicht nutzen, nach drei Monaten kommt noch eine dritte Person dazu, nämlich zum Beispiel unser Anwalt. Wenn ich angenommen, du kommst unter den Bus und dein Schlüssel verschwindet, würde ich ja nie wieder an die Kohle rankommen. Und dann läuft so ein Timer aus, nach drei Monaten. Kling! Und dann darf so ein Trusty das mit öffnen einmalig. Und dann würde man doch rankommen. Ich weiß noch nicht, wie sie das genau gedreht haben. Da müsste man jetzt das lange durchlesen, aber ich war auch kein Silk Road User, deswegen hat es mich nicht so richtig interessiert. Aber die meinten, das würde für viele Fälle helfen, auch dass man zum Beispiel irgendwelchen Exchanges, wo man Geld hin überweist, wo man sozusagen beide Seiten den Key behalten, dass, falls die dann pleite gehen, hops gehen oder was auch immer, dass nach einer Weile die Kohle wieder zurückkommt oder irgendwie so. Und das heißt, auch wenn es jetzt technisch vielleicht nicht ganz so super erklärt war, was ich eigentlich damit sagen will, ist, dass die an Bitcoin noch ziemlich coole weitere Ideen haben, was man so mit digitalen Währungen so machen kann, weil das würde alles mit normalem Bargeld zumindest nicht so einfach gehen, außer man hat halt wirklich wieder Tresoren mit zwei Schlüsseln und so weiter, aber da kann man nicht nach drei Monaten mal so eben einen dazuschalten, oder nach wie vielen Monaten auch immer. Und solche Features kommen halt bei Bitcoin und über so eine Sachen machen, die sich da Gedanken.
Und wie meintest du, würde dieses Proposal heißen? 38 ist irgendwas mit Passphrase Protected Private Key, da scheint mir was anderes zu sein.
Ja, warte, da muss ich nochmal in meine History gucken hier. Da war ich doch vorhin, Delayed Transactions gucken. BIP65 glaube ich. Genau. Ich kann ja mal hier, ich glaube, ich habe ja auch den Artikel von, wo es ein bisschen erklärt wird. Den können sich alle nochmal durchlesen.
Und da sind sie sich jetzt sozusagen alle einig, dass man das haben will und deswegen ist das jetzt schon in der Software vorbereitet.
Das wird kommen, so rum. Also es ist noch nicht drin, aber es wird kommen. Dieses Multisig ist wohl schon drin. Dieses Feature, das kommt dann in der nächsten Version wahrscheinlich.
Nicht schon wieder.
So, dann noch eine kurze Bitcoin-Geschichte. Und zwar seit, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Woche war oder noch ein bisschen mehr, sagen wir mal. Ja, ich glaube, die letzten 1-2 Wochen war das eine theoretische Bitcoin-Attacke. Und zwar, die streiten sich ja gerade drum, ob sie den maximalen Block-Size erhöhen oder nicht. Also alle 10 Minuten wird ja ein Block gefunden. Da sind die ganzen Transaktionen drin. Und dieser Block hat eine Maximalgröße von zur Zeit 1 Megabyte. Das heißt, mehr geht da nicht rein. Das heißt, wenn der Megabyte voll ist mit irgendwelchen Transaktionen, da gehen, glaube ich, so zwischen 800 und 1500 Transaktionen rein, dann ist er ungefähr voll, dann muss deine Transaktion, wenn die nicht mehr reinpasst, müsste die in den nächsten Block kommen. Und da streiten die gerade, ob man das nun erhöhen sollte oder nicht. Die Argumente sind, die Leute, die das erhöhen wollen, sagen, naja, wenn halt zu viele Transaktionen da sind, wir wollen die abarbeiten und deswegen muss der Block größer sein. Die andere Seite sagt, naja, ne, ist schlecht, wenn wir die Blockgröße größer machen, dann entstehen noch größere Blöcke, dann wird die Blockchain noch viel größer und wenn dann ein Attacker kommt und der die Blockchain mit kleinen Minitransaktionen vollspammt, dann hat er natürlich auch, denn erzeugt er nicht alle 10 Minuten einen Megabyte, weil die sind ja nicht immer voll, die sind ja, eigentlich sollten die immer kleiner sein, weil es nicht ausgenutzt wird, sondern dann hat er sogar schon zwei oder acht Megabyte oder 20 Megabyte, je nachdem, wie groß die Block-Cys halt hochschrauben wollen. Und dann könnte er ja sozusagen die Blockchain vollspammen, die auf deinem Rechner liegt, weil das ist halt ein Problem, du musst das ja alles irgendwie da halten und auch die Zeit, die diese größeren Blöcke brauchen, um sich weltweit zu verteilen. Das ist ja so ein kurzes Zeitfenster, dass die nicht parallel entstehen. Und wenn die so riesengroß sind, dann hast du so eine gewisse Latenz, bis die woanders ankommen. Und in der Zeit könnte ja ein anderer meiner schon wieder einen Block gefunden haben und dann entstehen zu viele Blöcke gleichzeitig. Also da gibt es sehr viel Pro und sehr viel Kontra. Und was, also ja, ich blicke da auch nicht durch, was nun wirklich am Ende besser ist. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum da jemand in den letzten eins, zwei Wochen das Bitcoin-Netzwerk mit tausenden Transaktionen vollspampt. Das heißt, das waren die letzten ein, zwei Wochen immer mehr Transaktionen als in so einen Block reinpassen. Das heißt, die ganze Zeit wurden ein Megabyte oder knapp ein Megabyte große Blöcke gemeint, bis auf so ein paar Ausnahmen an irgendwelche Miner, die das nicht interessiert und einfach gar keine Transaktionen in ihren Block reinmachen, kann man auch machen, aber dann verdienen die keine Gebühren, weil da sind ja Gebühren drin. Und das war das Problem, warum in den letzten ein, zwei Wochen Leute Überweisungen machen, also Transaktionen, die halt nicht ausgeführt werden, jedenfalls nicht sofort, weil da schon ganz viele andere Transaktionen drin sind, die warten. Also es waren immer so ungefähr 50.000 Transaktionen, die gewartet haben, dass sie in den nächsten Block reinkommen.
Das waren aber so Mini-Beträge wohl.
Das waren Mini-Beträge.
Wo Mikro-Bitcoins da hin und her geschoben werden.
Die kann man auch bei diesem Bitcoin Core 011, da ist auch, hast du jetzt das? Das richtige, kannst du mal ein bisschen scrollen, Transaction Flooding, da steht drin, was man machen kann, dass zum Beispiel der Bitcoin Demon oder das Bitcoin Gui, dass es halt die nicht alle aufnimmt, weil der sammelt ja auch alle ein und merkt sich die und so, dass die ein bisschen weggefiltert werden. Da kann man einfach die Minimum Relay Transaction Fee hochsetzen, die default zu 0,0001. Also das ist wirklich ein hundertstel Cent oder ein zehntel Cent oder ein zehntel Cent. Ich glaube, es ist echt schon ein hundertstel Cent. Dass man die einfach ein bisschen hochsetzt und dann werden diese Dust-Coins, nennt man sie, weil das ist halt nur Bitch-Staub. Das ist ganz klein, so heißt übrigens der Podcast von dem Jäger. Aber man nennt sie wirklich Dust, weil es halt nur so staub ist, ist nichts wert. Die werden dann weggefiltert und dann ist wieder okay. Aber die meisten Wallets zum Beispiel hatten auch gar keinen Feature, wo man die Gebühr, also die Fee, einstellen kann. Das heißt, alle Leute wollen natürlich möglichst eine Transaktion machen, die nichts kostet, weil es ja Geister Bitcoin soll ja umsonst sein und so weiter. Also jagen sie ihre Transaktion einfach so raus oder mit dem Standard-Algorithmus, der die größte der Gebühr berechnet. Und das war immer zu wenig, weil die kamen in den letzten zwei Wochen, kam nichts mehr durch. Und dann auch der Andreas Schildbach, der mit dem Jäggel dazu, der den Podcast macht. Ich weiß nicht, ob er es wirklich gemacht hat. Aber ich habe ihn auch im Bitcoin-Developer-Forum irgendwann kurz, habe ich gesehen, dass er irgendwas gefragt hat nachts. Also ich glaube, er hat es auch inzwischen schon längst eingebaut, dass man die Gebühr einstellen kann. Dass man sagt, okay, ich will aber, dass meine Transaktion in den nächsten Block drin ist. Also mache ich jetzt mal nicht hier ein hundertstel Cent irgendwie Gebühr, sondern ein zehntel Cent oder vielleicht sogar ein Cent oder noch mehr, dass er wirklich drin ist, weil ich will, dass meine Kohle irgendwie da ankommt, wo sie ankommt. Und das hat, also die Attacke hat auf jeden Fall dafür gesorgt, wie nennen sie es, dass ein Gebührenmarkt entsteht. Also dass man guckt, aha, wie stark ist dann das Bitcoin-Netz gerade belastet? Es ist sehr belastet, alles klar, ich zahle, ich setze meine Gebühren ein bisschen höher. Und wenn es nicht belastet ist, ok, dann zahle ich halt keine Gebühren, weil dann wird da ja auf jeden Fall aufgenommen, meine Transaktion. Und das ist auf jeden Fall jetzt in der letzten Woche eine Menge passiert. Ob der Typ, der diese Attacke gemacht hat, ich glaube, er hat sogar auch an eine Spendenadresse gespendet. Also er hat es nicht zu sich selbst geschoben, sondern ich glaube, er hat es irgendwo hingespendet. Also es ist auch nur das, da ist nicht so viel angekommen, aber da ist unklar, ob er das nochmal machen will oder ob das Sinn der Sache war, dass der Gebührenmarkt irgendwie so entsteht, dass das besser geregelt wird oder ob es wirklich böswillig war oder ob es wirklich nur ein Test war. Also viele denken auch, dass es ein Stresstest war und einfach nur mal ein bisschen getestet werden sollte, aber es hat sich keiner offiziell dazu bekannt bisher, wer das da gewesen sein soll. Manche sagen auch, dass es halt der Gavin Andresen, so heißt der, der will eher größere Blöcke haben. Andere Core-Developer sagen, ne, sie wollen diese großen Blöcke nicht, weil es ist halt ein Problem, dass einer von diesen Parteien halt diese Attacke gefahren hat, um auch irgendwie was zu beweisen. Das ist alles noch so ein bisschen, bisschen unklar. Da haben die so einen kleinen internen Krieg da gerade den.
Und du meinst, diese Attacken sind eher so, ich beweise dir mal, dass es geht, als dass da jetzt irgendwie...
Na, auf der einen Seite, das ist halt, deswegen ist es ja Pro und Conto und man blickt da nicht so durch. Auf der einen Seite könnte es sein, hier, ich beweise euch, ich haue euch so viele Transaktionen rein, die kriegt ihr nur weg, wenn ihr größere Blöcke habt. Das wäre das eine Argument. Man könnte aber auch sagen, dass da einer kommt und der sagt, ich haue euch so viele Transaktionen rein und dann seht ihr mal, was passiert wäre, hätten wir jetzt 20 Megabyte Blöcke erlaubt, dann würden alle 10 Minuten 20 Megabyte auf eurem Rechner gespeichert und würde voller und voller und voller werden. Und dadurch, dass wir aber nur 1 Megabyte haben, ist das nicht passiert, sondern es wurde künstlich limitiert und Leute, die halt trotzdem ihre Transaktionen durchkriegen wollen, die müssen halt die Gebühren ein bisschen erhöhen. Das ist unklar. Also deswegen, man kann nicht so richtig sagen, was da die richtige Entscheidung ist für die Zukunft.
Apropos Transaktionen, mir hat jemand letzte Woche irgendwie 2 Millibitcoin überwiesen.
Zwei?
2 Millibitcoin.
Ich dachte gerade, alles klar, mir auch, aber ich hab nur einen bekommen, verdammt. Und noch besser, muss ich mich überlegen?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich krieg das jeden Monat.
Milli oder Mikro?
Milli.
Zwei Milli. Milli.
Also ich hab einen bekommen und es sind zurzeit 26 Cent, weil der Bitcoin-Kurs ist ganz schön gestiegen, da ist jetzt schon mal 265 circa.
Ja stimmt, geht gerade wieder hoch.
Also viele sagen ja, dass es die Griechen-Krise ist, aber ich weiß auch noch nicht so richtig, ob die.
Also wir haben im Mai und im Juni für die Freak Show auch fünf und noch mal fast fünf Milli-Bitcoins.
Achso, ich wollte schon sagen, warte, du kriegst fünf Bitcoin? Ach nee, hast du auf Milli umgestellt?
Momentan ist Milli-Bitcoin.
Es sind schon immer noch viele Nullen, also alles mit vielen Nullen da vorne. Ab und zu mal ein bisschen weniger Nullen, aber selten.
So, das ist eine ganz schöne Liste.
Ich kann dir übrigens mal eine neue Spenden-Adresse geben, weil ich habe hier auf meinem Telefon eine Blockchain-Info-App, womit ich meine Burger im Room 77 bezahle. Und die muss ich immer von den Bitcoins auf meinem Rechner vollladen. Aber deswegen wäre es besser, wenn die Spenden Bitcoins gleich auf der Burger-Wallet kommen.
Was hast du denn so für einen Burger derzeit?
Ich kann ja mal gucken, was ich für meinen letzten Burger bezahlt habe. Moment, Moment, wo ist es da?
Bist du ja ungefähr so 0,01?
Also mein letzter Burger hat mich 0,08122031 Bitcoins gekostet. Ich glaube, da war der Kurs schon so bei 230 oder 234. Also 0,01 sind ja zur Zeit 2,60 Euro. Damals waren es vor zwei Wochen 2,30 Euro. Und 2,30 Euro mal 0,8. Weil es sind ja 0,08. Also so 20 Euro waren das.
Für einen Burger? Da war noch Wasser dabei.
Da waren zwei Apfel-Schorle dabei. Ich glaub, er hat gesagt 18 und ich hab gesagt, mach 20. Oder ich glaub, es waren 17 und 19. Irgendwie so.
Das ist echt eine Goldgruhe für den Herrn, ne? Also der vergoldet seine. Sind auch mit Blattgold dann die Burger eigentlich?
Nicht?
Das sind aber amtliche Burger. Also das muss man schon mal so sagen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, als würde man da nur so eine Hand voll bekommen.
Ich muss da auch mal wieder hinkommen. Wenn ich erst mal wieder hier dauerhaft in diesem Land bin, dann...
Also jedes Mal, wenn ich da ein Burger gegessen habe, hatte ich nicht das Gefühl, dass ich zu viel bezahlt habe.
Also wer sozusagen immer noch nicht weiß, was er mit seinen Bitcoins anfangen soll, wenn ich jetzt hier spende, denn ist hier direkt in seine Burger-Schatulle.
Da musst du erst noch nicht spenden. Peter, Timme muss erst die Adresse wechseln hier nach der Sendung.
Die ist ja auch überhaupt nicht veröffentlicht.
Ja, die Leihführer sollen sich halt ein bisschen die Füße schlagen.
Bitte noch nicht so viel spenden!
Aber das Coole bei Bitcoins ist halt, wenn da jetzt einer spenden würde, also jetzt gerade, dann würde es auch jetzt sofort klingeln. Das ist das Allergeilste. Das ist halt Bitcoin pur.
Ich meine, wenn einer Paypal zahlt, dann klingelt es auch gleich.
Bei Paypal sehe ich das gar nicht. Da müsste ich mich erst einloggen.
Und die sagt, du hast Geld erhalten.
Hier bei bitcoin.de schreiben sie Ochi, keine Gebühren für Griechen. Alle griechischen Staatsbürger zahlen bis auf weiteres keine Gebühren.
Können sie auch nicht mehr?
Ochi. Ochi. Ochi heißt es.
Ribonoklinsäure oder was?
Ochi Moron.
So, hat man noch was bei Bitcoin? Ich glaube, das war's. Ach so, wenn ihr eure Bitcoins ausgeben wollt, entweder im Room 77 oder beim Friedrich da in der Torstraße. Ich muss ja mal so ein bisschen Werbung machen.
Ja, oder in der Meta-Ebene.
Oder in deiner Wallet.
Ja, das hatten wir am Anfang, ja.
Ja, also es gibt genug Möglichkeiten, diese sinnlosen Bits, die euch nur verwirren und die ihr sowieso nicht versteht, abzuwerfen. Ja, Ende des Spendentals. Aber wo wir doch bei Krypto waren, ich bin halt total, ich bin halt voll kryptomäßig unterwegs. Ich weiß auch gar nicht warum, aber irgendwie war mir so in den letzten Tagen. Ich habe mich nämlich schon länger mit dem Gedanken getragen, einen GPG Key zu erneuern, weil einerseits mein Key, den ich hier seit längerem verwende, im nächsten Jahr ohnehin ausläuft. Und weil er auch irgendwie nicht mehr den aktuellen Leadness-Anforderungen entspricht. DSA 1024 bedeutet so viel wie kannst vergessen. Und man muss ja auch ein bisschen auf seine Hypnis achten und man geht halt nicht mehr ohne korrekten Key. Da wird man ja auch schon ein bisschen gedisst von den coolen Kids. Und nachdem halt wieder einige coole Kids auf Twitter so Bullying betrieben für Leute mit zu kleinen Key-Längen, wenn dein Key zu klein, zu kurz ist sozusagen, dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt gehe ich das mal an. Und ich fand das immer wieder, also ich meine, das ist ja dieses ewige Lied mit Leute benutzen Kryptographie nicht, weil es ist zu kompliziert. Und ich würde mich nun wirklich nicht für einen Krypto Wizard halten, so aber ich habe zumindest schon mal eine Weile, ich weiß schon einiges sozusagen von den Basics, ich habe auch schon mal ein Podcast mit Diffie Hillman gemacht, ich habe auch schon 1999 irgendwie schon mal meinen ersten Key angelegt.
Haha, lame.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es lame oder vielleicht habe ich noch schon früher angelegt, aber der einzige, den ich noch habe ist von 99.
Ja, mein erster ist von 94 und ich habe den noch.
Ich komme auch irgendwie mit Public Private Key, in der Theorie komme ich irgendwie klar, aber mit der Software ist das halt immer so eine Sache. Jetzt gibt es ja also auf dem Mac die GPG-Tools, die machen ja schon mal einiges wirklich ein bisschen einfacher.
Die gibt es auch seit drei Wochen für Yosemite, jetzt wo der Kapitän vor der Tür steht.
Ja gut, was auch immer sie da bis zum Ende noch optimieren mussten, das läuft auf jeden Fall. Und dann sagt sie mir, okay, jetzt mache ich das sozusagen mal unter vollem Einsatz der verfügbaren Software. Also ich fange jetzt gar nicht erst irgendwie an, Lead mir die Kommandeteile zusammenzubauen, die ich brauche, sondern ich wollte das sozusagen jetzt mit diesen installierten Bordmitteln machen. Und mal schauen, wie einfach das eigentlich ist.
Du meinst wie schwer.
Ja genau, also was würde mich jetzt sozusagen davon abhalten, wirklich mir jetzt mal so ein Key anzulegen, weil Krypto muss einfach sein. Ich meine, auf dem iPhone benutze ich Krypto die ganze Zeit mit Trima und mit iMessage. Da habe ich verschlüsselte Kommunikationen. Aber ich beschäftige mich nicht mit dem Vorgang der Schlüsselerzeugung. Also das oder? Also man benutzt das halt, man hat halt so ein Key. Das stellt sozusagen das System sicher und das ist schon so eine Definition von einfach. Kann man jetzt tausend Gründe anbringen, warum das irgendwie nicht cool ist, aber Tatsache ist, da wird halt Krypto die ganze Zeit benutzt und bei sowas wie E-Mail und anderen Sachen benutzt man es halt nicht, weil man irgendwie schon daran scheitert, sich überhaupt ein Key anzulegen. Also erzeuge ich mir ein Key. Genau.
Ja, das ist doch easy oder nicht?
Ja, schauen wir mal. Also ich benutze das Programm GPG Keychain. Da gibt es einen Button, der heißt New und dann ich dann irgendwie das aufmache, dann sagt er halt, erzeuge doch ein neues Key Pair.
Ja, in den Private und Public Anteil, ja?
Ja, also man muss echt schon eine Menge wissen, weil man denkt, man erzeugt sich einen neuen Key, dann ist es auf einmal ein Pair. Okay, gut, das mag jetzt mal gegessen sein. Dann gibt man irgendwie eine E-Mail-Adresse an, dann gibt es irgendwie die Passphrase. Soweit ist das ja auch alles noch in Ordnung, da gibt es Advanced Options.
Da sollst du ja auch nicht raufklicken, wenn du keine Ahnung hast.
Sind aber da.
Und?
Kann man aufmachen und dann sieht man das. Und dann steht da so was wie Comment.
Ja, das ist ja okay, das verstehen wir ja noch.
Das ist ein Kommentar, oder?
Man weiß nicht, für wen.
Naja, also das war schon etwas, wo ich mir dachte so, okay, warum muss das jetzt kommentiert werden? Wer liest diesen Kommentar? Wann liest ihr diesen Kommentar? Was soll dieser Kommentar ausdrücken? Soll er meinen Gemütszustand bei Erzeugung dieses Keys ausdrücken? Ist das irgendwie Motto of the day? Ist das ein Hinweis, warum ich diesen Schlüssel überhaupt erzeugt habe? Muss ich einen Kommentar machen, um zu erklären, wer ich bin oder wer ich nicht bin? Soll das irgendwie die Irre führen? Soll das irgendjemandem irgendwo bei helfen? Wobei soll es irgendjemandem helfen? Also diese Fragen sind vollkommen offen und wusste ich nicht. Da dachte ich mir so, okay.
Und bist du mal mit der Maus rübergegangen, ob da so ein Pop-Up-Help kommt? Wer das kommt jetzt?
Kommt nicht.
Nee, da nicht, du musst, oder? Muss man der schicken?
Vorne bei Comment auch nicht wahrscheinlich, ne?
Es kommt keine Hilfe und es gibt keine Hilfe.
Dabei ist es so einfach. Dafür müsste man nicht mal umprogrammieren, sondern nur in der Fest-Filder.
Aber die Frage ist, was würdest du denn da hinschreiben?
Ich weiß auch nicht, was es ist.
Experte halt. Ich nehme es mal vorweg. Ich habe dann ein bisschen mit Twitter geredet. Ich habe ein paar Links ergoogelt und auch genannt bekommen. Und bin am Ende vor allem bei einem Dokument von riseup.net gelandet, wo es einen elaborierten Auswurf über die Erzeugung von Keys gibt, bzw. die Nutzung von OpenPGP im Allgemeinen gibt. Insbesondere aber eben, wie man seine Keys konfiguriert.
Das ist aber ein langes Dokument.
Und das ist ein wirklich langes Dokument, wo eine ganze Menge TechSpeak drin ist. Und vor allem nach hinten wird es immer dünner und immer unerklärlicher. Wo du irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr weißt, wo oben und unten ist. Only use your primary key for certification and possibly signing. Have a separate subkey for encryption. Bonus! Have a separate subkey for signing and keep your primary key entirely offline. In this scenario, your primary key is used only for certifications, which happen infrequently. Also das ist sozusagen so, da bist du echt raus. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht der Punkt, worauf ich hinaus will, dass das jetzt ein kompliziertes Dokument ist. Hier wurde zumindest mal zusammengetragen und vor allem gab es irgendwie auch einen klugen Kommentar zum Thema Kommentare, nämlich don't use it. Kernproblem ist genau das Problem, was ich gerade angesprochen habe, nämlich keiner weiß so richtig, wozu diese Kommentare eigentlich gut sind, warum sie überhaupt eingeführt werden wurden und wer wem was in welchem Kontext worüber mitteilen möchte. Das Problem ist, dass verschiedene Software diese Kommentare teilweise dann mit in die E-Mail-Adresse noch in Klammern mit dazu macht und dann wird es irgendwie alles total missverständlich und keiner weiß mehr was genau ist und man soll auch bitte die Kommentare einfach nicht benutzen, because it's a feature that sucks. Kommen wir zurück zu unserer Key-Erzeugung und die zweite Advanced-Option, die mir angeboten wird, ist der Key-Type. Da hatte ich, glaube ich, letztes Mal schon ein bisschen drüber sinniert. Ich habe dann irgendwie auch mal wieder das Internet gefragt und naja, alle meinten irgendwie, man soll auf jeden Fall RSA benutzen. Dieses User Interface ist insofern nicht besonders hilfreich, weil es mir ja RSA and RSA anbietet, in Klammern Default, oder DSA and LGA mal, was offensichtlich nicht so toll ist. Und dann gibt es irgendwie noch zwei, mit denen man nur signieren kann und auch da wird irgendwie nicht wirklich erklärt, warum, was, also was sollte man nehmen. Gut, das ist der Default und dann bleibt noch die Sache mit dieser Key-Länge. Wenn du dann irgendwie auf Twitter fragst, was man irgendwie für eine Key-Länge haben will.
Lang.
Gegenteil von kurz.
Also mein Key ist 20 Jahre alt, da war 1024 angesagt. Ich habe gedacht komplizierte Zahlen sind bestimmt komplizierter, also habe ich 1234 genommen. Später habe ich irgendwann glaube ich 3456 genommen und weniger würde ich auch nicht nehmen. Also ich würde auch 4096 nehmen, eher mehr.
Ja vor allem, was hier auch überhaupt nicht erläutert wird, ist, was ist eigentlich die Konsequenz davon, dass es länger ist?
Das ist auch langsam.
Also wenn ein längerer Key lang ist, warum mache ich da nicht 30 neunen rein und rückritteuern?
Mach doch.
Na klar könnte ich das tun, aber die Frage ist, was ist der Effekt davon?
Learning by doing, mach.
Naja, learning by doing, ich kann dir sagen, wenn du das merkst.
Wenn es nicht geht.
Erstmal dauert wahrscheinlich das Erzeugen des Keys sehr lang und vor allem bedeutet es halt, dass auch jedes Verschlüsseln und Endschlüsseln sehr viel länger dauert.
Ja, ist ja Sinn der Sache.
Aber wie viel länger?
Sinn der Sache ist, dass es länger dauert, ihn zu knacken. Aber man kann ja nicht, es gibt ja hier überhaupt keinerlei Maßstab, der mir irgendwie sagt, das ist für heutige Nutzung eine angemessene Schlüssellänge, die eine Balance zwischen Sicherheit und Benutzbarkeit herstellt. Benutzbarkeit im Sinne von du musst nicht 30 Minuten warten, bis deine E-Mail verschlüsselt ist, weil das hilft dir irgendwie auch nicht weiter.
Also damals wurde das erklärt und da stand so da, du musst so und so viel nehmen, wenn du möchtest, dass deine Daten für die nächsten 20 Jahre sicher sind.
Ja, aber das steht halt hier auch nicht. Und Konsens ist, es gibt so ein paar hippe Freaks, die meinen, man muss auf jeden Fall mehr als 4.096 haben, weil dann hat man mehr als die anderen und die anderen meinen, 4.096 reicht.
97 zack.
Ja, und die klugen Dokumente sagen dir halt, das hängt davon ab, was du damit sichern willst. Sachen, die halt auch noch in 50 Jahren verschlüsselt sein sollen, sollten halt mehr haben und so. Also ich will mich gar nicht beklagen, ich sage nur, offensichtlich scheint der Konsens derzeit zu sein, 4.096 ist irgendwie okay und ist eine gute Balance zwischen, dauert nicht zu lange und ist irgendwie für eine absehbare Zeit sicher genug, aber grundsätzlich ist das natürlich schon auch wieder mal so eine Größe, mit der man eigentlich irgendwie nichts zu tun haben sollte.
Was bietet er denn so an? Zeig doch nochmal, klick mal drauf.
Er bietet mir nichts höher als 4.096 an, sehr wohl, aber noch 2.048 und 3.072. Auch da jeweils ohne weitere Erklärung, warum das jetzt ist. Also man könnte ja so ein Good Better Best oder ein irgendwie Fast, Convenient, aber sie bieten schon mal keine 1.024 mehr an. Sie bieten keine 1.024 an, was sicherlich angemessen ist. Nur was heißt jetzt 2.048, dass es dann, weiß nicht, dass ich schneller um die Kurven komme oder so?
Das ist halt auch die Frage, ist das halb so schnell oder ist das quadratisch oder ist das exponentiell ganz schlimm, irgendwie langsamer oder?
Eben, I don't know. Ich hab dann 4.096 genommen.
Ist ja lame, also so wie alle.
Ich bin total mainstream, was das betrifft, ne? Kommen wir zu der Sache mit Key expires. Ja, nein. Der Default hier ist, also das ist, wo gemerkt, eine Advanced Option. Also hätte ich das jetzt nicht ausgeklappt, wäre der Default gewesen, dass der Key nach zwei Jahren expires.
Ach echt, ohne dass ihr einem sagen müsst, ist ja auch geil.
Ich hab hier vier Jahre.
Und früher dachte ich auch immer, also das war auch immer so, dass man sich davon abgehalten hat. Ja, will ich jetzt einen Key haben, der ewig hält, ist ja auch blöd, was ist, wenn ich dann auf den nicht mehr zugreifen kann? Dann gibt es den Revocation Key. Ja, genau, Revocation. Aber was ist, wenn ich das genauso verliere, wie meine andere Passphrase? Ich meine, wenn ich eh schon meine Daten nicht zusammenhalten kann, dann finde ich den Revocation Key wahrscheinlich auch. Also ich meine, das ist ja dann irgendwie auch Wurst. Ob ich nun meinen Private Key oder meinen Revocation Key, die liegen am Zweifelsfall sowieso an der selben Stelle. Von daher ist das irgendwie... Ja, also was ich aber überhaupt nicht verstanden habe, und ich weiß nicht ob euch das irgendwie so bewusst ist, nur weil der Key aus-timet, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass man ihn nicht auch weiter benutzen kann.
Na ja, doch, klar.
Weil?
Ist so.
Ist sowas.
Naja, ich meine, irgendjemand muss das Expiren ja enforceen.
Die Software muss ja das Datum nicht kennen, deswegen das geht gar nicht.
Das ist lustig, ihr wisst das nämlich auch nicht. Man kann nämlich den Key auch verlängern.
Aber selbst wenn man ihn nicht verlängert, müsste es ja noch gehen, rein technisch. Reintechnisch geht das. Das heißt, es ist nur die Software, die dafür sorgt, dass es nicht mehr geht.
Sicher, die Software ist in Welle, sagt Rot, ist irgendwie, wird dich irgendwie warnen, oder dich irgendwie da...
Andere Leute davon abhalten, ihn benutzen zu wollen, weil da steht ja, der ist abgelaufen.
Er ist ja expired, genau. Aber was man halt tun kann, ist, du kannst jederzeit, auch wenn der schon abgelaufen ist, hingehen und sagen, je war alles nur Spaß, ich hab hier die Passphrase, ich verlängere den jetzt und jetzt ist er halt noch mal ein Jahr oder zwei gültig.
Ja, das geht dann über die Subkeys, oder wie?
Das geht irgendwie über die Subkeys, keine Ahnung, kann ich dir alles nicht erklären. Aber das ist dann sozusagen die empfohlene Marschrichtung. Das ist echt, sorry, ich bin nicht cool, aber das habe ich jetzt im Jahr 2015 gelernt. Dass das, und selbstverständlich ist das ein cooler Ansatz, weil wenn ich halt meine Daten verliere und dieser Key sozusagen nicht mehr verwendet werden soll, um mir Sachen zu schicken.
Wenn du ihn nicht verlängern kannst, dann läuft er halt ab.
Dann läuft er halt ab.
Das heißt, sie bei den Bitcoins wollen nur andersrum.
Genau, im schlimmsten Fall ist er halt nach einem Jahr oder zwei irgendwie markiert als bitte nicht benutzen. Und so kann ich aber immer noch kurz vorher sagen, nee, war alles nur Spaß, ich will den auch weiterhin benutzen.
Oder kurz nachher, ist ja egal.
Oder kurz nachher, genau, also ich kann das sozusagen jederzeit reaktivieren, kann denselben Key auf Key-Server schicken, etc. Sodass Leute theoretisch die Möglichkeit haben, wenn sie denn da auf diesen Key-Servern die Keys aktualisieren, dann würden sie davon in Kindes gesetzt. Passphrase eingegeben, zack, Key erzeugt. Hab ich gemacht. Dann hab ich noch ein bisschen weitergelesen. Und ein anderer Tipp, der mir sehr gut gefallen hat, das hab ich dann auch gleich gemacht, ist, also Hintergrund ist, ich hab jetzt einen 10 Jahre alten Key, der nächstes Jahr ohnehin abläuft, den ich nicht verlängern will, weil er halt irgendwie nicht mehr dem aktuellen Stein zwingt.
Du hast sie jetzt kreuzmäßig signiert.
Kreuzmäßig hab ich sie noch nicht signiert, aber ich hab den neuen mit dem alten signiert.
Das war aber auch vor 20 Jahren schon so angesagt.
Kann ja sein. Ich spreche nicht von neuen Erkenntnissen, sondern nur sozusagen von meinem frisch neu zusammengefegten Erkenntnissen, was man eigentlich alles so wissen muss, wenn man sich ein GPE Key Key erzeugen will. Das sind so Fragestellungen, die irgendwie einem entgegengehalten werden, zumindest wenn man so eine Software benutzt, wie ich das jetzt hier gemacht habe. Du sagst, ich sollte den alten Key auch nochmal mit dem neuen signen und den auch nochmal auf den Key-Server tun?
Ich wusste noch nicht mehr, welche Richtung, aber deswegen habe ich Cross gesagt. Das Ding ist ja, dass halt...
Das ist ja eine Botschaft.
Der neue Key könnte ja theoretisch von irgendwem kommen. Das heißt, wenn der den alten signiert, das heißt ja gar nichts. Dann wissen wir immer noch nicht, ob der neue Key wirklich der echte Tim ist. Wenn aber der alte Key, wo ich weiß, dass es der Tim ist, wenn der alte Key den neuen signiert, dann ist das schon irgendwie...
Genau.
Das habe ich jetzt gemacht. Es kann aber auch sein, dass dein alter Key geklaut wurde und du hast dir deswegen neuden gemacht. Und da signiert einer mit dem alten Key, den er dir geklaut hat, einen anderen. Das heißt, deswegen Cross macht eigentlich am meisten Sinn. Dann weiß man von beide Richtungen, die wollten miteinander irgendwie...
Ja, aber wenn er geklaut ist, dann sagt das über den neuen Key auch nichts aus. Also so Keyverlust ist irgendwie immer bekloppt und da hast du halt auch ein Problem, Trust zu erzeugen. Da komme ich auch gleich nochmal dazu, weil da kommt ja noch was Neues ins Spiel. Naja, auf jeden Fall habe ich jetzt diesen neuen Key erzeugt. RSA 4096, kein Kommentar. Mit den von mir gebräuchlichsten E-Mail-Adressen auch. Also man kann ja dann dem Key auch noch verschiedene E-Mail hinzufügen. Oder identitäten heißt das ja, glaube ich. Oder wie heißt das? Jetzt muss ich mal kurz schauen. User-IDs kann man hinzufügen. Das sind nicht die Sub-Keys. Sondern du sagst sozusagen nur, dass auch für diese E-Mail-Adresse dieser Key gelten soll. Das ist ja nicht wirklich nochmal ein neuer Schlüssel, der da erzeugt wird. Sondern das ist sozusagen nur so eine Attached-Information mit das sind die E-Mail-Adressen, wo dieser Key üblicherweise zum Einsatz kommen soll. Sub-Key habe ich in dem Sinne nur einen. Und ich wüsste jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, wofür ich jetzt noch weitere bräuchte. Brauche ich jetzt noch einen, damit ich noch in die Disco komme oder? Unklar, ne? Also man könnte jetzt noch weitere Sub-Keys anlegen, die auch irgendwie expiren.
Naja, man könnte seinen Master-Key behalten. Die Leute können ja, wenn die dein Master-Key signieren, dann kannst du darunter ja neue Sub-Keys erzeugen. Oder ging das nicht? Ich glaube, das ging nicht, weil die signieren halt pro Sub-Key oder pro ID. Weil du kannst ja dann sonst was hinschreiben, Präsident oder so, sonst was. Und dann haben die das schon fertig signiert. Das geht natürlich nicht. Das heißt, ja.
Und dann könnte ich noch ein Foto mit in den Key reinmachen.
Das Foto hab ich auch bei mir, ist sogar unterschrieben von C-Punkt. Ja, hab ich ihn ausgetrickst irgendwie. Warum ich ihn ausgetrickst hab oder warum?
Warum den ausgetrickst hast, ist mir schon klar.
Weil es ging, keine Ahnung, wenn man mit rumspielen wollte. So ein uraltes Foto hab ich mal da reingeklatscht und irgendwie, ich glaub, C-Punkt hat sich irgendwie vertan und hat das aus Versehen mit signiert, weil er fand das Foto eigentlich voll blöd und aber irgendwie ist es passiert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum man jetzt unbedingt, also der Punkt bei Fotos ist ja, man will, ja was will man eigentlich damit sagen? Man will sagen, ja hier, das ist die Fresse, die zu diesem Key gehört, du kannst hier sicher sein, oder das kann ja auch jeder in jeden Key irgendwo was reintun. Das ist halt immer dieses Problem, du weißt halt nicht, wie dieses Key herkommt.
Aber andere, die mich dann signieren, sagen ja, das ist das Foto zu den passenden Typen und dann können andere kommen, die mich nicht kennen, optisch, können dann sehen, alles klar, so sieht er aus und können sich irgendwo dann vielleicht mal drauf verlassen. Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist es auch nur Datensammlerei, weil dieses ganze Signieren ist mir auch immer so ein bisschen scary, weil da gibt es ja diese Tools im Internet, wo man halt alle Relationen von allen Keys zueinander und so sehen kann und wer was mit wem zu tun hat, da brauchst du nur von einem den Key mal schnappen, da reinwerfen und dann sagt er dir, wen der alles kennt und weil da hat er Signaturen von.
Ja, das ist halt diese Web-of-Trust-Problematik. Ich hab jetzt meinen Key derzeit von niemanden signieren lassen und ehrlich gesagt, weiß ich nicht so richtig, ob man das überhaupt unbedingt will, muss haben, braucht, keine Ahnung. Ich hab auch das Gefühl, damals diese ganzen Key-Signing-Parties, das ist halt auch so ein bisschen so Sign my ass. Das ist mehr so, ich guck mal, wen ich kenne und wer mich signt.
Ja, das sollte eigentlich dafür sein, dass ich dich signiere und dann kommt jemand, der mich gut kennt und der sieht dann alles klar, Dennis hat den Timme gesigned, dann ist der Key von dem Timme wohl der richtige, weil er weiß ja erstmal nicht, ob er den richtigen Key vor dich hat und über Umwege macht er das dann. Aber ja, hat vielleicht nicht jeder so den direkten Draht zu dir, dass das so geht oder das will man nicht, weil es zu viel wäre, aber ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man das so über Umwege sich sein Trust haben will, also dieses Lab of Trust, ich bin da auch nicht so fan. Ich finde das bei Stream eigentlich ganz cool, das ist irgendwie rot, wenn du noch nie gesehen hast, das wird so orange, wenn du das über dein Telefonbuch machst und die Person irgendwie wohl angeblich die richtige Telefonnummer hat, so ungefähr, wie du das schon immer in deinem Telefonbuch hattest, und es wird erst grün, wenn du den direkt irgendwie abgescannt hast. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz okay, dann hast du die Person auch mal gesehen und dann weißt du, okay, der stand zumindest schon mal vor mir.
Aber jetzt leben wir ja in einer neuen Welt, in der es ja auch ganz andere Methoden gibt, sich zu authentifizieren und zu sagen, wer man denn ist. Und ich würde sagen, dass zum Beispiel mein Twitter-Account sehr viel mehr Glaubwürdigkeit vermittelt oder zumindest Bekanntheit vermittelt. Wenn also irgendetwas sich konkret auf meinen Twitter-Account bezieht, dann wissen Leute, ah, das ist etwas, das wurde sozusagen signiert von jemanden, der Kontrolle über den Twitter-Account hat.
Über diesen Twitter-Account glaube ich, haben eine ganze Menge Leute Kontrolle.
Plus andere Sachen.
Welche? Du meinst, es gibt so viele Quellen, um an dein Key zu kommen, dass es schwierig ist, dass sich da einer reinschummelt.
Ich will nur darauf hinaus, das ist ja schon seit Längerem, ich glaube, das haben wir ja auch schon mal besprochen, als das irgendwie gelauncht ist und ich benutze das jetzt sozusagen oder hab das jetzt sozusagen auch nochmal neu ausgegraben. keybase.io. Das ist ja im Prinzip so ein Projekt, was eben genau dieses Problem angehen möchte, nämlich ich möchte gerne mitteilen, was mein Key ist und möchte den Leuten aber Anhaltspunkte geben, halbwegs vertrauenswürdige Anhaltspunkte geben. Dass ich das auch bin und dass das auch mein Key ist. keybase.io ist eine Webseite und ist ein Set von Command Line Tools. Kann man sich mittlerweile auch über Homebrew installieren. Brew install Keybase. Gibt auch einen Installer natürlich auf der Webseite. Wenn man sich da einen Account geklickt hat, dann kann man da halt sagen, hallo ich bin Tim Pritlav, mein Key ist... und guck mal, ich bin es wirklich, weil ich habe hier mit meinem Key auch die Autorisierung meines Twitter Accounts gesigned, meines GitHub Accounts gesigned, Metaebene ME, Tim Pritlav Org. Und theoretisch kann ich hier auch noch weitere Webseiten reinbauen und sie haben noch irgendwie Support für Reddit, Coinbase, Hacker News, warum auch immer. Man kann auch irgendwie eine Bitcoin-Adresse setzen, was ich mal gemacht hatte, aber jetzt nicht mehr. Und jetzt können andere Leute, die hier auf Keybase einen Account haben, mich tracken. Wenn du jetzt einen Account hättest, könntest du halt sagen, ok, ich möchte jetzt Tim tracken. Was heißt das?
Erstmal in dem Moment, wo du mich trackst, meinst du tatsächlich mit deinem Key, also mit deinem GPG Key über dieses Keybase Tool auf der Command Line diesen Tracking Vorgang. Und du kannst dann irgendwie mit Keybase Pull all die Leute, die du trackst, die Keys automatisch von Keybase holen, die Public Keys, und in deine Keychain importieren. Das heißt, alle Leute, die ich jetzt auf Keybase tracke, wenn die sich einen neuen Key zulegen, wenn ich Keybase Pull mache, habe ich alle ihre neuen Keys bei mir. Und die alten sind irgendwie weg.
Aber das kann doch das GPG Tools auch. Die haben da auch ihren Key-Server und dann drückst du einmal und werden die alle geupdatet. Und hochgeladen wird der auch von.
Ja, aber du weißt ja auch dem Key-Server nicht mehr als irgendeine Key-ID. Du suchst auf so einem Key-Server, findest irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse, aber du weißt ja nicht, ist das jetzt wirklich der Key.
Ja, du meinst ein bisschen mehr, wo sie das testen, ob es der richtige ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt, wo ich meinen neuen Key auf den Key-Server habe, da weißt du ja nichts von. Wenn du da irgendwas updatet, der wird ja nicht der alte mit dem neuen Key jetzt ersetzt.
Du hast ja mit dem alten den neuen unterschrieben. Der neue läuft auch als Tim Pridluff, dann kriegst du den auch.
Nein, du würdest eine neue Version meines alten Keys bekommen, wo unter Umständen der neue Key gesigned hat oder sonst irgendwas, als das Expiredate geändert ist. Aber du würdest nicht automatisch den anderen Key, nur weil da meine E-Mail-Adresse ist, bekommen und vorgesetzt bekommen als der wahre, richtiges Key. Dann könnte ich dir jeden Scheiß Key vormachen. Dann schreib ich hier irgendwie Andi Müller-Margon und Tralalaas.
Müller-Margon hat ja den nicht signiert mit seinem alten.
Ja, aber du musst dir den angucken und dir selber darüber eine Meinung bilden. Hier bei Keybase, wenn du jetzt, ich hab jetzt einen neuen Key gepostet. Jeder, der mich trackt, macht einfach Keybase Pull und hat den neuen Key.
Ja, die vertrauen dann also Keybase?
Nein, die vertrauen meinen Aussagen, die ich auf Keybase gemacht habe. Weil ich ja bewiesen habe, dass ich ich bin, weil ich hier über zahlreiche Quellen belegt habe, dass ich Kontrolle über wichtige Domains habe, die mich als mich ausweisen. Also, wer irgendwie wissen will, dass ich...
Also, die Keys kommen dann nicht von Keybase, sondern Keybase liefert nur die Information, wo man die holen kann und die holen das dann von den Domains da.
Na ja, du lädst ja dein Public Key da hoch. Und signs das aber auch und wenn du dann... Also, ich habe einen neuen Key hochgeladen und musste dann all meine Authentifizierungen bei Twitter und so weiter noch mal komplett neu machen. Also, die blieben nicht, sondern ich musste dann noch mal bei Twitter, Proof my Identity, tralala, mit meinem neuen Key was signen, was dann ich getwittert habe.
Das war das Letztes, verstehe ich.
Das hatte ich jetzt letztens, genau. Bei GitHub machst du einen Gist. Auf deiner Webseite musst du einen entsprechenden Eintrag in SRV DNS Record machen oder irgendeinen File auf dem Webserver hochladen, et cetera. Und damit habe ich sozusagen bewiesen, dass ich jetzt über vier verschiedene Outlets Kontrolle über diesen Key habe. Ich bin in der Lage, meinen Key auf meinen Webseiten zum Einsatz zu bringen, auf meinem Twitter-Account, auf meinem GitHub-Account. Und wem das jetzt nicht ausreicht zu glauben, dass das wirklich jetzt von mir geht, dem kann ich jetzt auch nicht helfen. Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist halt hoch genug, um es vielleicht mal zu probieren, mir eine verschlüsselte Mail zu schicken. Im schlimmsten Fall wäre sie halt unverschlüsselt. Und so kann man zumindest davon ausgehen, dass das mich verschlüsselt erreicht. Was KeyBase ja auch macht, es erlaubt dir ja sozusagen auch, dein Private Key hochzuladen. Da rumpft der Hacker mit dem Näschen und lupft die Braue.
Da fällt dem Hacker die Mate aus der Hand.
Also, dass sie diesen Service schon anbieten, sind die schon durchgefallen. Hat mir das beim letzten Mal auch schon?
Moment, stopp, stopp, stopp. Ich hab da ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht. Und ich verstehe ja, was du meinst. Und irgendwie...
Nee, da gibt es einfach keine Ausreden.
Doch, doch, doch. Denk mal, folgendes. Denk mal anders drüber nach. Derzeit benutzen wir dieses GPG. Ich hab ja eben gerade den Heiligen Prozess beschrieben, einen Key in die Welt zu setzen. Was hab ich mir Gedanken machen müssen?
Die Heilige hat Granate?
Komplexe Webseiten durchlesen müssen mit irren Erklärungen, die kein Normalsterblicher auch nur ansatzweise versteht. Das ist einfach eine Geheimwissenschaft. Dieses Key erzeugen, das geht gar nicht.
Da hättest du aber diesen Button nicht drücken müssen.
Egal, es sind ja Fragen, die mich betreffen und ich muss dir das ja irgendwie qualifizieren. Also wenn die Optionen da sind, dann sind sie halt in der Welt.
Du warst nur neugierig.
Das System könnte ja auch die Annahmen einfach durchsetzen und sagen, du willst Expiry haben, du bist gezwungen, dein Key irgendwie zu verlängern. Das machen wir jetzt einfach so, du nimmst RSA, du hast 4096, Schluss, halts Maul and take my Key.
Wäre ja jetzt auch nicht so falsch gewesen, oder?
Nö, aber ist nicht so. Ist nicht so.
Ja gut, und jetzt, was ist da besser?
Ich sage nicht besser, ich sage nur, wer sagt denn eigentlich, dass dieses ganze Key-Management auf der Basis laufen muss, dass ich so den einen Key habe? Warum soll ich mir nicht auch noch einen Key machen, den ich über Keybase mache? Den benutze ich dann irgendwie nur dafür. Und den benutze ich irgendwie, damit mir jemand mal eine Datei schicken kann.
Ja, und dann denkt derjenige, das ist voll wichtig und Keybase wurde schon seit drei Wochen gehackt und weiß ich, wer den Key dann schon hat.
Klar, aber wenn du jetzt casual mal eben was verschlüsselt austauschen willst, ohne auch groß mit Tools und gestellten GPG-Installationen arbeiten zu wollen, dann hast du halt hier eine Basis, mit der du das auch machen kannst. Du kannst da halt mal eben im Web was verschlüsselt für irgendeinen anderen Keybase-User, kannst dir was schicken und du hast hier sozusagen ein enkryptet Ding. Du musst ja nicht diesen Key rausgeben mit der Maßgabe, alle geheimen Leaks der NSA, bitte ab jetzt an mich auf diesen Keybase-Accord. Darum geht's nicht.
Aber da hättest du auch dem so deinen Key zukommen lassen können oder sonst, wie vor allem verschlüsseln kann der immer für dich, weil deine Keys sind ja public, also der Public-Anteil. Also mir fällt kein Grund, warum man da sich seinen Key von denen machen lassen sollte.
Auf jeden Fall kann man auf jeden Fall ein Key da irgendwie hochladen und damit rumspielen. Und man kann ja auch wieder rausschmeißen. Und man muss das ja irgendwie, nicht für wichtige Sachen benutzen, aber ich finde, das ist die einzige Plattform, die ich bisher gesehen habe, die überhaupt einen halbwegs spielerischen Ansatz auch mit Verschlüsselung und Datenaustausch hat. Wo man mal eben was entkrypten kann und die sich zumindest Mühe geben, es richtig zu machen. Ob die es richtig machen, andere Frage. Sie sagen ja auch selber, wenn du das machst, ich hoffe, du weißt, was du tust, Browser sind irgendwie potenziell gefährlich. Das ist sozusagen nicht das, was wir jetzt unbedingt empfehlen, aber wir ermöglichen es auch, weil es halt auch mal praktisch sein kann, sowas auch zu haben als Werkzeug. Weil wenn man immer nur auf die reine Lehre setzt, dann kommt man unter Umständen auch nicht weit. Naja, also was ich nicht so richtig verstehe, ist, warum man hier immer noch Invites braucht, bevor man mich fragt, ich hab keine.
Wo sehe ich denn, habe ich noch Invites?
Von daher ist das irgendwie alles ein bisschen komisch. Und ich will halt auch irgendwie, ja, ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht preisen oder so. Ich sage nur, ich benutze das, weil ich das beobachte und weil ich das irgendwie bisher ganz praktisch finde und es löst halt zumindest dieses Problem mit wer hat einen neuen Key und wie kriege ich diesen Key dahin, wo ich ihn brauche. Und jetzt muss ich halt einfach nur Keybase Pull eingeben und fertig ist die Laube. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wo er Invites herkriegt, aber irgendjemand wird bestimmt welche haben. Vielleicht muss ich alle mal meine benutzen, weil die Invites, die ich irgendwie verschickt habe, irgendwie huckel, wollte es irgendwie sein, nicht haben. Vielleicht habe ich doch noch zwei, die ich frei machen kann. Aber nicht für Hörer, sondern die gebe ich jetzt an euch weiter, wenn ihr sie haben wollt. Du hast ja schon einen. Dennis will nicht. Okay, dann weißt du, was jetzt passiert? Jetzt bricht wieder eine Twitter-Wolke über mich ein.
Ich, ich, ich, ich.
So ist das halt als Podcaster. Ja, das sind die Gedanken, die ich mir zur GPG und Key-Erzeugung gemacht habe. Na ja, immerhin habe ich mir welche gemacht. Vielleicht habe ich ja unrecht. Das könnt ihr mir dann alles in den Kommentaren erzählen. So, bevor ich jetzt aber weiter über Flash rede, da freut die mal.
Ach so, ja, Mindmapping. Ich weiß nicht, das ist vielleicht nicht für jeden irgendwie ein großes Thema. Aber ich habe neulich entdeckt, dass das Mindnode in der Version 2 erschienen ist.
Ist Mindnode identisch mit Mindnode Pro?
Mindnode Pro war die Pro-Version von der 1. Und es gibt jetzt aber Mindnode 2, die haben jetzt keine Pro-Version mehr, sondern es gibt nur noch die eine Version, die man halt bezahlt. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab. Ja, ist schick, also kann man einfach benutzen.
Kannst du nochmal das Konzept Mindmapping erläutern?
Na, Mindmapping ist so eine Art Ideengenerierungstool. Man könnte sagen, es ist ein Outliner in 2D. Also sprich ein Outliner, wo...
Ist ein Outliner, wie viel D hat der noch mal?
Nein, weil es ist eine Liste. Die Sachen sind halt eingerückt. Und bei einer Mindmap hast du diesen Baum. Ein Outliner ist ja ein Baum. Und bei einer Mindmap geht der Baum um die zentrale Note komplett herum. Nein, das eine ist 1D. Doch, es ist eine Liste von oben nach unten. Das ist eine Dimension, fertig.
Die hat noch eine zweite Dimension, die ist nämlich die Einrückung.
Na gut, dann ist es 3D.
Aber du kannst nur nach rechts einrücken.
Nein, das ist genau dasselbe. Es gibt genauso viele Ds, es sieht nur anders aus. Deswegen habe ich nie richtig verstanden, was der Unterschied zum Beispiel einer Outline und einer Mindmap ist. Aber vielleicht kannst du mir das ja erklären.
Du kannst nicht nach links einrücken.
Also man könnte sagen, eine Mindmap ist eine andere Darstellung, die auch den Platz besser ausnutzt. Zumindest dann, wenn man nicht zu lange Zeilen schreibt. Es gibt Leute, die finden es gut. Du findest es offensichtlich jetzt nicht so brauchbar. Ich finde es so als Tool ganz in Ordnung. Sagen wir es mal so. Die Idee ist ja, dass man seine Ideen sortiert, indem man die Äste dranhängt und die Äste umschichten kann, sodass man immer weiter ein Gefühl dafür kriegt, was denn jetzt zentraler an dem Problem ist und was perifärer an dem Problem ist. Weil du dieses Zentrale und Perifere relativ gut sehen kannst. Keine Ahnung, das ist so. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht jemand, der eine Mindmap tagtäglich verwendet oder das als für das allerbeste überhaupt. Aber wenn man eine benutzen will, dann ist Mindmap Pro schon ein gutes Tool.
Okay, zweite Frage. Ich habe bisher ein Mindmapping Tool noch nie etwas anderes machen sehen als diese Mindmap und ich frage mich immer, was sie eigentlich in den neuen Versionen dann hinzufügen, was die Mindmap-Experience in irgendeiner Form verbessert.
Na, es wird immer bunter. Keine Ahnung, wenn man die erste Version nicht hat, kann man die zweite durchaus benutzen. Also es ist so, ich bin jetzt so ein bisschen, also ich habe das vor allen Dingen auf die Liste gesetzt, weil da aus dem Kollegenkreis noch ein zweites Mindmapping-Tool kam und das heißt X-Mind. Und X-Form, am Anfang eines Namens klingt schon so nach X-Server und nach grottiger Software. Wenn man es dann runterlädt, ne, das kriegst du nicht im App Store. Wenn man es dann, also mir ging es so, ich hab's dann mal runtergeladen und hab's mir mal angeguckt, aber das ist, also, ja, das kommt so in so einer Eclipse-Optik daher. Jaja, also ich hab das dann auch gleich wieder zugemacht.
Cross-Plattform.
Das ist Cross-Plattform und man kann sogar die Basisversion tatsächlich umsonst benutzen. Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, was man jetzt unbedingt machen muss, möchten muss, damit man dann nicht mehr die Basisversion benutzt. Aber irgendwie hat so diese Optik von dem Programm an sich mich erstmal abgeschreckt, obwohl die Maps, die man so machen kann, eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht ist. Also bei uns benutzt es die QA, um so die Test-Stories so ein bisschen Mindmap-mäßig aufzublasen. Und da sieht man dann eigentlich auch relativ schön, was hab ich getestet, was hab ich nicht getestet und was ist schiefgegangen und muss noch buggefixt werden und was nicht. Also insofern.
Wofür benutzt du das?
Was? Das Mindmapping selber? Na so zum Ideenraum abgrasen, im Prinzip. Also könnte man jetzt natürlich auch einen Outline benutzen.
Jaja, eben.
Aber ich finde, dass eine Outline einen relativ früh in eine Struktur festlegt, von der man jetzt nicht so genau weiß, ob das die Struktur ist, die man haben will.
Du kannst auch eine Mindmap in OPML exportieren und dann hast du dasselbe.
Ja und?
Und du kannst eine Outline in OPML exportieren und in eine Mindmapping-Software reinladen und du hast auch dasselbe. Richtig?
Ja, ich will aber nicht exportieren. Ich will einfach klicken und dann...
Was mich Frage ist, warum haben Outliner keinen Mindmap-Modus und warum haben Mindmapper keinen Outline-Modus?
Das ist eine Frage, die ich dir nicht beantworten kann.
Weil das hab ich irgendwie nie so richtig verstanden. Also eigentlich, wenn es doch dasselbe ist, warum ist da nicht beides drin? Also warum... Also wenn dieser View so toll ist, mit diesem automatischen Ich klapp mich auf und ich stöp mich irgendwie über den Bildschirm, warum ist das nicht im Outliner drin? Und vor allem, warum ist kein Outliner in dem Mindmap? Weil manchmal finde ich einfach gerade diese Collapsed View und textuelle Darstellungen, die ja auch gegenüber der Mindmap noch einen entscheidenden Vorteil hat im Übrigen. Sie hat eine Reihenfolge. Du hast halt in diesen Mindmaps keine Reihenfolge. Das hat mich schon immer so ein bisschen gestört.
Ja, aber das gehört natürlich so ein bisschen dazu, dass du die nicht hast. Weil sie dich davon löst, durch die Reihenfolge Prioritäten im Hinterkopf zu haben.
Ja, aber manchmal gibt es aber so eine Reihenfolge.
Oder? Manchmal gibt es eine Reihenfolge, ja. Aber dann ist Mindmap vielleicht auch nicht das richtige Tool dafür.
Mindmap ist sozusagen Outliner ohne Reihenfolgenpflicht. Wenn man keine Reihenfolge haben will, dann benutzt man eine Mindmap. Ich will das jetzt nicht schlecht machen. Das kann ja durchaus sein, dass das jetzt das Argument ist. Also dass man sich sozusagen von der leicht verhärteten Struktur durch Reihenfolge löst und sagt, alles ist frei und fließt.
Das ist schon so eine Art Brainstorming-Tool.
Trotzdem arbeitet man mit Hierarchien. Dinge gehören zu Dingen, gehören zu Dingen, die zu Dingen gehören. Das ist ja sozusagen das, was man da ausdrückt.
Genau, genau. Aber das Schöne ist halt, du kannst die Äste so umsortieren. Wenn du denkst, ich hab da eine Idee und das gehört dahin, dann kann man das halt mehr zur zentralen Note hin migrieren.
Ja gut, das kannst du dann wiederum auch im Outline. Das ist ja sozusagen das Verschieben von Bäumen.
Nein, dazu gehört natürlich auch einfach der Überblick. Also ich finde, man kriegt halt schnell einen Überblick. Also man bekommt zumindest das Gefühl, man hat jetzt diesen Baum, diesen Ast, dieses Geästel da. Und alles, was in dem Geästel drin ist, ist jetzt irgendwie, damit habe ich das Problem jetzt einmal abgegrast. Und wenn nicht, dann mache ich noch irgendwo einen Baum ran. Und ich kann das aber alles in einem Bild angucken. Also keine Ahnung, es wird jetzt langsam esoterisch. Aber ich finde, für manche Dinge ist es ganz schön.
Ja.
Ist denn das bei dem Mindnode, war das dann so, dass man sozusagen die, also fließen die auch irgendwie automatisch?
Ja, ja, die sind. Du machst da einen Ast und dann machst du einen neuen Ast.
Und gibt es dann mehr als nur einen View, wie sie sich automatisch ausbreiten? Also gibt es da so verschiedene Flow-Mechanismen?
Ich hab jetzt ehrlich gesagt...
Weil so ist das ja zum Beispiel auch in Omni...
Ja, Omni Graffle ist natürlich nochmal ein ganz anderes Tool.
Ja, ja, ist ein anderes Tool, aber der hat...
Was ich auch gerne benutze übrigens, aber...
Ja, ja, aber der hat ja auch tatsächlich so einen Modus, wo du sagen kannst, jetzt sortier das mal hier alles nach so einem bestimmten Layout Schema neu.
Ja, das habe ich nie benutzt.
Na gut, wir empfehlen das. Mindnode für Outlines ohne Reihenfolge. Und ich würde gerne Omni-Outliner empfehlen für Outlines mit Reihenfolge.
Also du...
Ich bin immer noch total angepisst, wenn ich mal an dieser Stelle sagen darf, dass Omni in Version 3 den Styled Text als Pflicht gesetzt hat und den Unstyled Text rausgenommen hat und das war der größte Fehler, den sie je gemacht haben.
Also du hast hier bei dem jetzt noch so eine Art On-Outline-Ansicht.
Wie bei dem hier?
Bei MindNode. Naja, ich hab jetzt hier, ich kann jetzt da noch ein, machen wir hier noch ein Sub-Ast ran und noch ein Sub-Ast. So, und dann zeigt er mir hier in der Übersicht, das quasi als Outline.
Und kannst du da die Reihenfolge ändern?
Könnte ich ja mal versuchen. Dazu muss ich diesem jetzt aber erstmal einen neuen Namen geben. Kann ich die Reihenfolge ändern?
Nee, scheinbar nicht.
Weil manchmal stört mich das so ein bisschen bei dem Sortieren meiner Gedanken, wenn ich die Dinge nicht in eine Reihenfolge bringen kann.
Und ich denke manchmal stört es andere Leute, wenn sie irgendwie das Gefühl haben, sie müssten ihre Dinge in eine Reihenfolge bringen. Und vielleicht ist das genau der Grund, warum dieses Tool existiert.
Na, aber wenn die Reihenfolge egal ist, dann ist sie ja auch so egal, dass sie ja auch in irgendeiner beliebigen Reihenfolge sein können. Aber es ist dann halt egal. Aber wenn es halt nicht egal ist, dann hast du zumindest eine. Weil wenn es egal ist, dann ist es halt egal. Irgendeine Reihenfolge, dieses Programm erzeugt ja auch eine Reihenfolge. Du hast sie bloß nicht unter der Kontrolle.
Optisch ist da keine.
Doch, in diesem komischen Outline, den du mir gerade gezeigt hast, ist ja sehr wohl eine Reihenfolge. Aber du kannst sie halt nicht beeinflussen, wenn sie dich stört. Wenn du halt jetzt irgendwie deinen Obst sortierst und sagst irgendwie Ananas, Tralala, Apfel und du willst dann aber irgendwie dann doch die Zitrusfrüchte irgendwie beieinander haben, weil sich da wohler fühlst und das Gefühl hast, du hast dann auch wirklich alle Zitrusfrüchte beisammen. Oder jetzt gleich eine Kategorie Zitrusfrüchte zu machen, weil das macht dann deine Mindmap irgendwie kaputt, weil darum geht es nicht.
Doch, du kannst sie umräumen, aber du musst es dann in der eigentlichen Mindmap umräumen.
Ah, es gibt dann schon eine grafische Reihenfolge oder was?
Naja, Uhrzeigersinn, würde ich mal sagen.
Ich denke, das Thema ist erschöpft.
Mir sind Outlines wichtig.
Jaja, das wissen wir. Outline ist das neue Kalender. Ja, ich fand's nett. Also, ja, kann ja jeder Scheiße finden.
Wer will jetzt? Dennis?
Ja, geht schnell, kurz und schmerzlos.
Meinst du?
Jo, klar.
Das wird bestimmt spannend.
Clemens ist nicht da.
Ich weiß. Er wird jetzt wieder schmerzen.
Ist mir egal. Ja, mir auch. Ist ja ganz easy. Können den ja sogar referenzieren, den Clemens, weil der hat ja schon mal hier, mehrmals auch in der letzten Sendung, glaube ich, wenn er da war. War das in der letzten oder in der vorletzten? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ja, wir hatten ja da ausführlich schon drüber gesprochen, dass Apple jetzt verschiedene Maßnahmen zur Förderung von IPv6 bespaßt hat.
Clemens hat auch noch mal kurz wieder erklärt, was dieses Happy Eyeballs ist, und zwar, dass kurz IPv4 und IPv6 mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig getestet wird. Und das, was schneller geht, das wird genommen, damit die Eyeballs halt happy sind, weil wir wollen halt unseren Content schnell sehen. Weil aber teilweise, glaube ich, auch die IPv6-Adressen noch irgendwie durch so ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, getunnelt werden oder irgendwie so jedenfalls zeitlich einen kleinen Nachteil haben, könnte nicht müssen, sondern könnten. Und irgendwann gibt es auch keine Tunnel mehr, dann ist es gleich schnell oder schneller. Jedenfalls, weil das so sein könnte, dass es langsamer ist, hat Apple sich gedacht, und ich weiß nicht, ob es nur Apple ist oder ob die das manchmal verkauft. Apple verkauft ja gerne Sachen, die alle machen, aber als wenn es von ihnen allein ist. Deswegen bin ich mir da nicht so sicher. Aber jedenfalls gibt es da von The Register einen Artikel, dass Apple wohl dem IPv6 25 Millisekunden Vorsprung gibt. Das heißt, wenn die IPv4 Antwort kommt, dann zeigen sie die nicht sofort an, sondern sie warten noch mal weitere 25 Millisekunden. Das ist jetzt echt nicht viel, weil sind ja nur mal 1000 davon in einer Sekunde. Wenn innerhalb dieser 25 Millisekunden doch noch eine IPv6 Antwort kommt, dann nehmen sie die halt. Sie warten nicht auf den, der schneller ist, sondern IPv6 kriegt 25 Millisekunden Vorsprung. Und die meinen, in dem Artikel steht irgendwas, dass dadurch dann halt von allen Adressen, wo halt es beides sein könnten, doch eigentlich immer IPv6 gewinnt.
Das Ganze bezieht sich übrigens auf ein Posting von einem Apple-Mitarbeiter in einer IPv6-Mail-Liste, wo er das sozusagen ausführlich darlegt. Das ist David Ski-Nazi, das ist auch ein sehr gesegneter Name. Core OS Networking Engineer. Und da stellt er das sozusagen auch nochmal in eine korrekte Liste. Erst wird sowohl V4 als auch V6-Adressen erfragt vom DNS. Und wenn das nicht im Cache ist, dann wird es halt irgendwie über DNS angefragt. Aber erst fragen sie nach der V6-Adresse. Dann nach der V4-Adresse. Und wenn sie als erstes V6 kriegen, dann machen sie auch sofort V6.
Ja, das ist sehr klar. Also das war ja schon auch vor diesen 25 Millisekunden so früher. Also der, der zuerst kommt, gewinnt.
Und wenn sie aber erst die V4-Adresse kriegen, dann starten sie diesen Timer. Und wenn sie innerhalb diesen Zeitraums eine V6-Adresse bekommen, dann machen sie halt trotzdem V6. Und das ist halt irgendwie, im Prinzip wird es dazu führen, dass einfach mehr V6-Abfragen starten. Was sagen sie von 50-50 auf 99 Prozent?
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch klar. Stell dir vor, du hast wirklich den Rechner, der hat, oder dein Rechner oder mein Rechner, wie auch immer, hat IPv4 und IPv6. Und du hast auch keinen IPv6-Tunnel, sondern die sind beide pur, gehen bis dahin, haben genau den gleichen Weg, die gleichen Router, das gleiche alles. Ich glaube, okay, IPv6 hat einen minimalen Nachteil, weil die Adressen sind halt doch ein bisschen länger. Das heißt, das Paket ist minimal größer, also hat es einen leichten Nachteil, aber mehr oder weniger kommen die gleichzeitig an. Das heißt schon rein statistisch, mal ist IPv4 schneller und mal ist IPv6 schneller. Und deswegen steht da 50-50. Das heißt, mit diesen 25 Millisekunden sorgt es dafür, dass zumindest, wenn die auch gleich schnell sind, immer IPv6 gewinnt. Also IPv6 müsste schon wirklich ziemlich viel schlechter sein, damit IPv4 genommen wird. Und dann ist es ja okay, weil wir wollen ja Happy Eyeballs. Und die Idee ist ja, die schreibt ja auch nicht umsonst auf die Liste und ich denke mal der Ansatz, ich weiß nicht, ob das andere auch schon gemacht haben, wo die das herhaben oder so. Es kann ja auch sein, dass sie es einfach nur wieder geklaut haben irgendwo. Ist ja nicht unüblich. Aber vielleicht greifen das andere ja dann auch auf, falls es noch nicht so ist. Und das sorgt für noch mehr IPv6-Traffic. Und wenn man sich, ich hab letztens halt, nachdem ich diesen Artikel gelesen hab, hab ich mal gegoogelt, wie doll denn der IPv6-Traffic so ist. Und was schätzt dir, wo der jetzt so ist? Bei Google?
Du meinst so World Wide?
Ja, also ne, was bei Google ankommt natürlich, was die da so im Überblick haben.
Was bei Google ankommt an V6-Traffic World?
Ein Prozent, ein halbes Prozent, zwei Prozent, fünf Prozent, zwanzig, fünfzig?
Fünf würde ich schätzen.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind schon auf dem Weg zu zwanzig. Zwischen zehn und zwanzig?
Ne, sieben waren's. Aber das ist auch schon bedeutend, weil da ist, kannst du ja mal, müsstest du eigentlich im IPv6 stats und Google oder so, IPv6 stats, da gibt's ja mehrere. Vom Amp6 gibt's auch welche, kann man überall gucken, das haben die großen, ja ISPs, wollte ich das ja gar nicht mehr nennen, sondern großen, ja, big companies haben das, Statistiken drüber. Kann man mal sehen, wie schnell das ansteigt. Haha, kein Flash. Ja, da geht's auch wieder los.
Ach, Google braucht Flash, um die Statistiken anzuzeigen?
Um den Bild anzuzeigen, ja.
Ja, das Thema kommt gleich. Ja, sorry.
Kann Flash denn schon IPv6?
Konnte es das denn? Nicht?
Wie lame.
Ja, da ist es. Also da kann man schon sehen, 2009, 2010, da ist noch nicht, da ist eigentlich fast noch gar nichts passiert. Also ist alles noch unter 1%. 2011 sieht man schon, dass was passiert, aber alles noch unter 1%. 2012 auch noch, aber da geht's schon so ganz schön hoch. Das ist übrigens das, das, das gleiche, die gleiche App oder ist ja jetzt Flash, diese auch für ihren Google Stocks benutzen, die kann man genauso da ziehen. Jedenfalls ab, ab 2000. Alter, was hast du jetzt? Jetzt sind die Werte auf einmal plötzlich so hoch.
Na, ich hab ja mal den Zeitraum auf da, wo es jetzt wirklich spannend ist.
Aber jetzt ist ja bei 2009 auch schon über, über ein Prozent plötzlich.
Ab Anfang 2013 waren wir bei ein Prozent.
Ich hab da unten die falschen Jahreszahlen gelesen. Okay, die sind ja zweimal gelistet. Okay, 2013 ist er dann jedenfalls die 1%-Hürde durch. 2014, also letztes Jahr, da hat er am Jahresanfang war er bei, bei knapp 2,5%, würde ich mal sagen, ist er bis Ende 2014 schon so bis auf 5 gekommen. Er ist ein bisschen drüber schon. Dieses Jahr, und wir haben ja gerade erstmal ein halbes, sind wir jetzt schon bei über 7. Diese Wellen, die du da übrigens siehst, die so hoch und runtergehen, wenn du da mal ran zoomst, weil ich hab mich schon gewohnt, da haben die scheiß Statistiken, woran das wohl liegt und so weiter. Aber da gibt es auch eine ganz interessante Erklärung. Das sind die Wochenenden.
In den Wochenenden geht es hoch oder runter? Hoch.
Hoch.
Die Leute haben auf Arbeit.
Alle vor 4, zu Hause vor 6.
Genau. Oder sie surfen halt. Also von Arbeit wird nicht so viel gegoogelt wie von zu Hause.
Krass. Und das macht einen Prozent aus.
Circa ja.
Aber das ist ja das Verhältnis, ne?
Wie meinst du das Verhältnis?
Na zwischen 4 und 6. Also ich glaube eher, dass die, dass sie auf Arbeit nicht unbedingt vor 6 haben. Interessant finde ich hier die Statistik von Akamai.
Dass sie auf Arbeit nur IPv4 haben.
Von Statistik von Akamai sagt 34 Prozent in Belgien.
Ja, ich glaube, also früher war es, glaube ich, Frankreich. Aber da könnte Clemens auch mehr erzählen. Aber ich glaube, da gab es irgendeinen Provider. Also von Frankreich kenne ich das ja schon vor ewigen Jahren. Einfach da mal IPv6 gemacht hat. Und dann sind die da voll nach vorne geschossen. Und vielleicht, Belgien ist jetzt nicht allzu groß, hat das da auch irgendein Provider gemacht. Und dann gehen die natürlich total ab.
Ja, T-Mobile hat jetzt angekündigt, dass sie v6 im Mobile-Netz machen wollen.
Ja, aber die haben das, glaube ich, schon ganz oft angekündigt.
Das wäre mir neu, dass sie das oft angekündigt haben.
Also vielleicht jetzt nicht so megaoffiziell, aber da gab es schon ganz viele Interviews, wo sie 2010 gesagt haben, Ende 2011, und 2011 haben sie gesagt, ja, dann Sommer 2012.
Interviews, aber jetzt war es ein Tweet.
So richtig offiziell.
Ja, richtig offiziell.
Und aber ohne Datum.
Wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, geht es um dieses Jahr, also soon. Werden wir sehen. Macht ja auch Sinn. Ja, macht ja auch total Sinn.
Aber wie läuft das dann? Können das dann alle DSL Modems schon und so weiter und so fort?
Mobile.
Für Mobile?
Für Telefone.
T-Mobile.
Ach so, du hast nicht T-Mobile. Na ja gut, aber es haben schon ein paar Leute T-Mobile. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die v6 anschalten...
Die fünf Leute da.
Das ist... Da ruckelt es ein bisschen im IPv6.
Da wird auf jeden Fall... Erstens sind es viele.
Wahrscheinlich muss man dafür einen neuen Vertrag abschließen.
Zweitens sind da halt keine beknackten Easy-Boxen oder schlecht konfigurierte Fritz-Boxen, die mit v6 nicht klarkommen dazwischen.
Oder moderne Telefone meistens.
Sondern da ist das Endgerät halt der direkte Gesprächspartner. Das heißt, das Netz gibt dem Telefon eine v6-Adresse in dem Moment und dann ist da halt auch native v6 am Start. Und damit müssen sie halt auch keinen Carrier Grade Not mehr machen.
Und trotzdem standardfilterweise Angst haben wetten.
Sie könnten sogar theoretisch halt dazu übergehen und gar keine v4-Adressen mehr ausgeben, wenn sich alle abso verhalten, wie das Apple fordert. Ab September sozusagen.
Also bisher haben die Telefone ja auch so eine 19, 18-Adresse und dadurch auch sind die Ports zu, weil man nicht durchkommt. Die Frage ist, weil man eine native IPv6-Adresse kriegt, ob, ja, wie das dann aussieht.
Die werden schon Mittel und Wege finden, den Dienst noch ein wenig einzuschränken.
Ich denke auch.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es schon mal der Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Wir können uns auch noch mal die per-country IPv6-Adoption anschauen. Letztes Mal war ja Deutschland vorne, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne?
Belgien war vorne.
Da hab ich auch drauf gelegt. Da sind die Stats aber auch nicht so wirklich klar. Ich meine, du kannst ja noch mal auf Europa klicken und dann kann man ja wohl noch mal mehr auswählen. Gibt es dann näher ran? Wird dann gezoomt?
Nö, nee, Deutschland ist auf einmal nicht mehr so gut. 16 Prozent Adoption. Belgien 34,7. Schweiz 20,96. Wir sind wieder sozusagen Frankreich nur 5,5.
Aber die Zahlen von Akamai sind sehr ähnlich.
Also UK 0,17 Prozent, das merke ich.
Aber warum ist da noch nicht knallrot?
Wo?
Okay, müsste doch dann dunkelrot sein.
Unklar.
Das gehört nicht mehr zu Europa deswegen.
Interessant finde ich bei Akamai diese Platzliste auf Platz 4, das ist Peru.
Ja, was im Wesentlichen damit zu tun haben dürfte, dass diese Länder......denen früher die Adressen ausgegangen sind? Genau, die haben einfach keine V4-Adressen mehr.
Das ist Nord- und Südamerika zusammen als Adress.
Und vor allem alle machen mobile und da funktioniert das halt einfach mit dem V6.
Ist durch.
Eigentlich ist es durch.
Zimbabwe 0%, Italien 0%. Indonesien 0%, Mexiko 0%. Turkey 0%.
Hier fragt jemand, du sollst noch von China gucken.
Von China?
Nee, hier Timber per Country. Per Country.
China bei Akamai 1%. Platz 32.
0,91%.
Naja, ungefähr der gleiche Wert.
Das sind aber auch schon 10 Millionen Leute.
Jaja, das sind schon viele, klar.
Mehr als in Belgien wetten.
Auf jeden Fall.
Aber noch weniger als in Deutschland.
16%, ja.
Oh man, aber das Bhutan eine bessere Prozentzahl als Russland hat und Kanada und Indien.
Aber es wird langsam. Also der Graf geht deutlich nach oben. Also wenn wir Ende des Jahres sind, wir auch so wie es aussieht locker bei 10%, oder? Ja, ich denke mal, das geht jetzt auch exponential, dann geht das alles ganz flott.
Das wird jetzt alles exponentiell.
Ja, ich denke schon.
Zum Thema exponentielle Änderung hättet ihr auch noch einen anderen Vorschlag zu machen. Und zwar Flash.
Aha, haben wir unser Dings?
Unser Dings?
Unser Dschingel, unser Flash-Dschingel.
Ach so.
Hast du den nicht mehr?
Gute Frage. Das ist so eine Sache. Ja, das kommt jetzt ein bisschen zu schnell. Aber eigentlich, eigentlich, warte mal.
Na ja, langsam brauchen wir auch keinen Flash-Dschingel mehr.
Nein, ist er?
Doch, gerade zum Abschied nochmal.
Ist hier ausgeschaltet.
Achtung. Ja, die hatten wir schon so lange nicht mehr.
Das stimmt.
Insofern war das ja angemessen. Flash, genau. Was ist passiert? Eigentlich nichts, außer, dass ja hier irgendwie diese italienische Cyber Security Mafia. Genau, die Versager ohne Moral.
Das auch noch, ja. Hat da auch jetzt keiner Mitleid, oder? Also ich kenn keinen.
Nö, auch nicht die anderen Leute, die jetzt da so zurückgetreten wurden in der Folge davon.
Muss man da drauf nochmal eingehen. Vielleicht wissen viele Leute ja gar nichts über das.
Ja, also Management Summary ist, es gibt auch nach wie vor aber vielleicht bald auch nicht mehr, weiß nicht, eine Firma die heißt Hacking Team, allein der Name schon, in Italien und die verkaufen halt so Software an alle erdenklichen Staaten und sonstige Bösewichte für teuer Geld, die halt so Zero-Day-Sicherheitslücken ausnutzen, um ja Leute überwachen zu können, Trojaner zu installieren etc., halt all dieser ganze Scheiß, all dieser ganze unmoralische Kram, um irgendwie Leuten auf die Spur zu kommen, die versuchen irgendwie die Welt zu einem besseren Ort zu machen. Und genau diese Super-Hacksworts sind jetzt mal richtig amtlich, gesuperhackswort worden, richtig gesuperhackswort worden und zwar nicht nur mit so einem lächerlichen De-Facement auf einer Webseite, sondern so richtig einmal komplett der gesamte Datenbestand des ganzen Ladens. 400 Gigabyte irgendwie als Torrent ins Netz.
Plus alle Mails.
Genau, plus alle Mails, wo wir noch viel Spaß haben werden und wo jetzt auch schon interessante Erkenntnisse gefunden wurden.
Source Code, sämtliche Exploits sind jetzt bekannt und so weiter.
Exakt und das ist natürlich auch ein Problem, weil sozusagen auf einmal Minisdienis Sicherheitslücken bekannt wurden, die bis dahin nur Hacking-Team oder zumindest der wenigen Leuten und Hacking-Team bekannt wurden. Darunter wohl auch eine größere Teilmenge an Adobe Flash Zero Days. Wie sollte es anders sein? Sodass jetzt irgendwie das letzte Update, was Adobe jetzt rausgeworfen hat, mal so glaube ich so in der Größenordnung von 35 Security-Fixes hatte. Was jetzt auch nicht so ungewöhnlich ist für Adobe, aber das war halt irgendwie fertig. Ja und auch nicht viel, genau für Flash meinte ich damit auch. Und als dann eben zum Wiederholten male dir, es gibt eine neue Flash-Version, willst du updaten? Und ich frage mich dann immer so, habe ich nicht irgendwie schon lange Auto-Update angeklickt? Funktioniert das überhaupt? Oder heißt Auto-Update bei denen nur? Wir nerven dich und dann führen wir dich schon wieder durch diese unsägliche Kaskade von Installationsschritten, die ich hier schon mal beklagt habe. Naja, und dann dachte ich mir so, du hattest es doch schon mal komplett deinstalliert. Wie hat sich denn das eigentlich wieder auf dein System gefressen? Und ich muss halt zugeben, dass ich einfach durch den Zwang, durch Webseiten irgendwann keinen Bock mehr hatte, immer wieder diesen Umweg durch andere Browser und Chrome zu gehen und dann doch irgendwie Flash installiert habe. Und wie das immer so ist, man gewöhnt sich ja an alles und macht immer brav seine Updates und denkt, wird schon nichts passieren. Und dann hatte ich aber jetzt irgendwie die Lust verloren und dachte mir so, jetzt schmeiße ich dich irgendwie weg. Und vor allem hatte ich auch echte Akku-Probleme mit meinem Laptop. Also ich habe so meinen Laptop mit 100% geladen irgendwo ins Kaffee gestellt, zwei Stunden rumgehackt und das Ding war irgendwie am Ende. So wie früher. Ich konnte es mir nicht so richtig erklären, warum eigentlich. Siehe da, jetzt mal Flash weggehauen, jetzt hält der Akku wieder. Wunder! Aber so richtig, so richtig so lang und wow, I've got a new computer. Weil das System meinte ja auch immer so, Battery-Condition wäre total mint und super und was hast du denn, alle Daten sehen gut aus. Hat wohl was gebracht. Und dann bin ich mal so durch diese ganzen Webseiten durchmarschiert, die noch vor ein, zwei Jahren mir immer diese Probleme bereitet haben und durfte feststellen, oha, oha, hat sich ja doch ganz schön was getan. Vor allem deutsche News-Webseiten, all voran Spiegel Online, aber nicht nur, haben tatsächlich, also bei Spiegel Online, ich hatte da noch jüngst gerantet bei Lockbruch Netzpolitik, dass die ja auch zu dieser Gruppe von Leuten gehören, die einem immer dieses Flash aufdrücken wollen. Das stimmt auch für Spiegel TV. Genau, bei Spiegel Online ist es vermutlich vor einem Monat eingeführt worden, sagte mir jemand.
Die hatten ja auch diesen Flash-Artikel, weil der neue Facebook-Security-Guy gesagt hat, hier Flash sollte man jetzt mal abschalten, Adobe sollte mal 18 Monate oder so nehmen und dann mal so einen Kehl-Switch irgendwie einführen, dass die Browser dann da mitmachen können. Und in dem Artikel am Ende hat Spiegel ja auch ein bisschen selbstreflektierend gezeigt, naja, wir versuchen auch schon umzustellen, aber zum Beispiel halt hier diese Videoecke, die haben wir auch noch nicht. Und hier so alte, wo so interaktiv Grafiken kommen oder auch ihre Fußballgeschichten, da weiß ich auch nicht, ob die wahrscheinlich, die können sie auch nicht so von heute auf morgen umstellen, sehe ich auch ein, da brauchen sie ein bisschen. Aber für Video muss das nun echt nicht sein. Und da habe ich aber auch mal probiert und dann, witzigerweise, die Werbung ist gleich mal komplett weggefallen, die vor den Videos dran war. Die kam nicht mehr. Mit HTML wieder oder was? Nee, also vielleicht ist das auch mein Flash, weil deswegen habe ich auch das andere, was nicht ging.
Nee, gibt immer noch Werbung. Ich habe auch zu den einen...
Haben die Werbung nicht, da kam gleich so ein Symbol, nee geht nicht, weil es kein Flash. Dann wurde der Bild aber schwarz, also das Fensterchen in dem Fenster. Und dann habe ich das Audio gehört, aber kein Bild gesehen. Also irgendwie, dann ist doch mein Rechner kommt dann nicht so mit klar mit ohne Flash. Muss ich vielleicht nochmal, keine Ahnung.
Cleanser machen?
Oder nochmal neu starten. Vielleicht hängt da ja auch irgendwo noch was drin. Ist eigentlich der zweite Usafti, der war gar nicht für dich?
Nee, das ist für dich. Du musst unbedingt mal deinen Mikrofon wieder in die richtige Richtung... Nee, das ist eine Niere.
Mit der Nieren.
Naja, was heißt Niere? Nein, das...
Ich sehe das ja gar nicht.
Genau, das ist das Problem.
Ja, genau, dann schau doch mal hin, man. Guck mal, eine Niere heißt, dass die Spitze der Kugel wichtig ist. Willst du da mal was? Na, mindestens.
Und diese Flash-Sache...
Eine Minute bist du wieder von Badan reden.
Das waren jetzt Exploits, die aus dem Leak rauskamen? Oder ist das Leak über einen Flash-Exploit passiert? Oder ist noch gar nicht klar, wie sie eingebrochen ist?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob da jemand schon Erkenntnis hat. Ich hab von keinem gehört.
Also es geht allein um den Inhalt dieser 400 Gig?
Ja.
Also, ich weiß auch nicht...
Wie die ausgewertet werden.
Alle Sicherheitslücken, die sie gefixt haben, darauf zurückgehen, aber auf jeden Fall einige.
Aber das müsste doch jetzt noch ein paar andere treffen, auch noch, ne?
Das dauert vielleicht ein bisschen länger.
Das trifft bestimmt eine ganze Menge. Aber mir geht es ja jetzt erstmal um Flash. Und was wollte ich jetzt nochmal sagen? Ah ja, genau. Dann hab ich halt überlegt und nochmal geguckt. Was sind denn jetzt eigentlich noch die Zwänge, die dieses Flash eigentlich am Leben erhalten? Was geht denn eigentlich nur mit Flash? Und ich glaube, also erstmal, was du schon erwähnt hast, es gibt halt so komplexe Anwendungen, Editoren in Flash, die irgendwie Zeug machen, die sich, weiß ich nicht, entweder mit HTML5 nicht so ohne weiteres bauen lassen oder zumindest in der Form noch nicht unbedingt alle nachgebaut worden sind, weil es irgendwie komplexe Tools sind. YouTube zum Beispiel hat in seinem Backend für die Owner der Videos halt so einen Videobearbeitungs-Editor, der schreit nach Flash. Dann ist es irgendwie auch noch so ein bisschen unklar mit Streaming. Du kannst halt mit Flash auch so Livestreaming machen und...
Was ist denn mit HTTP-Streaming?
Ja, also das geht mit dem Video-Tech, nur heißt das natürlich auch, dass deine Server-Infrastruktur auch entsprechend umgestellt worden sein muss. Das heißt, wenn du Flash-Streaming machst, dann setzt du halt unter Umständen auch Adobe's Flash-Streaming-Server ein. Und das ist sozusagen auch so eine Infrastruktur-Frage. Ja, das stimmt. Trotz alledem, da bin ich jetzt selber ein bisschen am Schwanken, falls da jemand Erkenntnisse hat, da wäre ich mal über gute Pointer ganz dankbar, weil ich habe so ein wenig versucht herumzulesen im Netz und bin irgendwie nicht so richtig schlau rausgeworden, ob denn oder in welcher Form eigentlich der HTML5-Video-Standard beziehungsweise auch die Implementierung natürlich das abdecken. Also RTSP zum Beispiel als Streaming-Protokoll so ist halt da nicht mit abgedeckt. Sehr wohl könnte man aber eben über Websockets oder sowas Streaming machen, nur das macht halt kaum einer. Das HTTP-Livestreaming wiederum, was Apple macht, ist halt Apples Variante, dann gibt es Adobe Variante und Microsofts Variante und der Standard, der das halt mal werden soll, der ist zwar mittlerweile bei der W3C spezifiziert. Der Dash Standard, Dash, ja ich glaube Dash. Aber ich habe sozusagen keinen Überblick darüber, inwiefern das jetzt da ist, benutzt werden kann, auch fehlerfrei funktioniert etc. Und dritte Sache, die auch noch auffällig ist, offensichtlich gibt es hier und da wohl auch HTML5-Fallbacks. Also mir ist das zum Beispiel auf so ZDF-Kinder-Fernsehenseiten, hier so tv.de und so was aufgefallen. Da kannst du zwar ohne Flash auch an die Videos rankommen, aber du kriegst sie dann halt in niedriger Qualität und kannst die Qualität nicht umstellen. Also du kriegst halt auf einmal kein HD mehr und damit sind viele Sendungen dann irgendwie auch, also nicht nur kein HD, sondern du kriegst eigentlich auch kein SD. Du kriegst halt irgendwie so Web-Schrott, wo irgendwie nichts mehr ordentliches zu erkennen ist. Und das geht natürlich auch gar nicht, dass du dann eben auch so ein Qualitätsvollback hast. Was natürlich ja auch wahrscheinlich wieder so eine Schleife ist. Wenn dann jemand ein Problem hat, dann sagen die, ja dann installier doch Flash. So, dann hast du. Dann haben wir das Supportproblem nicht mehr und lalala. Also da ist irgendwie der gordische Knoten noch nicht so richtig durchgeschlagen, um das jetzt voranzubringen.
Das sind aber alles so öffentlich-rechtliche Programme, die haben halt ihren 5-Jahres-Plan und da sah das zweimal hintereinander Flash aus Rollen vor.
Ja, wobei die sind auch teilweise weiter als andere. Also auch tagesschau.de zum Beispiel, ARD, das Team hat schon vor langer, langer Zeit angefangen, mit Webstandards zu arbeiten und auch alternativ auch auch irgendwie auch Ork anzubieten. Das scheinen mir irgendwie eh so ein paar Linux-Freunde zu sein, die da administrativ tätig sind für diesen ganzen Kram. Nur eben diese Komplettverweigerer mit hier Flash und nix anderes und ich zeig dir jetzt hier auch gleich noch das Adobe-Logo und klick hier und Download Now und so, das sind halt so die richtigen Problemheimer. Also Tagesspiegel zum Beispiel. Du kriegst ein Video und dann so, äh, Flash, äh, geh weg.
Tagesspiegel, naja, manchmal findet man noch eine Webseite, wo gar nichts angezeigt wird ohne Flash.
Da wär auf jeden Fall mal ein ordentlicher Shitstorm fällig.
Ist eigentlich Vimeo, machen die auch Flash oder HTML?
Die machen schon sehr lange HTML5-Video. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau, wie die gestartet haben, aber da war das schon deutlich vor YouTube okay. Was für mich auch einer der Gründe war, mir mal ein Vimeo-Account zuzulegen. Ja, so sieht's aus in der Welt. Mehr können wir dazu jetzt auch nicht mehr sagen. Denn sowohl unsere Themen sind durch, als auch unser niemals konkret angestrebtes, aber trotzdem immer wieder erreichtes, Zeitziel.
Zeitbudget ist alle.
Ja, ist alle. Ist leer. Muss mit Bitcoins wieder aufgeladen werden. Ja Leute, ähm...
Wir haben über den neuen iPod Touch gar nicht geredet. Also nicht, dass es da was zu reden gäbe, aber...
Ja, gibt's halt.
Gibt's halt.
Der ist doch nur so Apple-Scheiße oder nicht?
Und einen neuen iPod Nano, der noch ein sehr iOS 6-mäßiges Design in der Software hat.
Der ist ja eigentlich neu, der hat nur eine neue Farbe.
Ach so, na dann.
Wie auch der Shuffle. Neu ist nur der Touch. Ja, sie haben halt den alten Scheiß weggeschmissen und bauen jetzt den gleichen Kram ein wie ins iPhone 6. Das macht ja auch Sinn, weil sie wollen ja dieses Teil bestimmt so als Spielkonsole demnächst preisen.
Steht groß Metal in der... auf der Website.
Genau. Jetzt mit Metal. Jetzt mit Metal.
Und mit dem fetten A8-Chip.
Jetzt mit Heavy Metal.
Schneller als mein Telefon.
Echt? Was haben wir denn in unserem 5S?
Na, ein ASM oder so.
Ich bin ja voll hinterher, verdammt.
Aber wir werden auch hinterher bleiben müssen, weil das nächste iPhone...
Genauso scheiße aussieht wie das letzte, ja.
Sieht genauso scheiße aus wie das letzte und...
Das 6S.
6S und ist halt vor allem auch genauso groß. Und ich weiß nicht, ich...
Vielleicht bringen sie ja, weil vielleicht sehen sie ja, dass doch viele so eins haben wollen.
Ich glaube, die sehen eher, dass viele Leute einfach trotzdem die großen Flügel kaufen. Und ich hasse die Leute da draußen, die das tun dafür. Ich will 4 Zoll. Oder ich kaufe mir ein iPod Touch mit einem...
Mit einem Wifi-Ding.
Nee, das willst du wirklich nicht. Nein, nein, nein. Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wenn sie kein iPhone mehr in der Größe anbieten, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Dann muss man irgendwann in die Tischkante beißen, aber ich hoffe, dass es dann nicht mehr so scheiße aussieht.
Das Tischkante beißen?
Nein, das Telefon. Weil das ist no beauty, das Teil.
Der Bildschirm ist schick, aber...
Nee, es geht nicht.
Zu groß.
Es sieht auch nicht aus.
Der Bildschirm schon.
Ja, Kamera zeigt raus.
Das war noch Zeiten, wo es noch hieß, the back of this is more beautiful than the front of the other.
Aber hallo, genau. Da ist doch einiges zu holen. So nicht, ja, so nicht, so kriegt er uns nicht hier unsere Gunst erkauft. Ist nämlich gar nicht so einfach. Wir sind nämlich Freaks.
Jammern auf hohem Niveau.
Genau, jammern auf hohem Niveau. Hier so gut wie nirgendwo. Ja, wiss ich, wollen wir der Endung eine Sendung bereiten? Der Sendung ein Ende bereiten.
Ja, wenn es denn ein würdiges ist.
Ein würdiges Ende. Ich guck mal, was sich da machen lässt. Guck, das ist doch sehr würdig, oder? Kommt alle aufs Camp, schaut euch die Freak Show live an. Seid einfach dabei und danach erzählen wir euch, wie es war, wenn ihr nicht gekommen seid.
Wenn ihr gekommen seid trotzdem.
Thank you for coming.